[Musique]
c'est pour ça que je me lève tous les
matins pour ça je mets l'écoute et
l'humain au centre de tout
oui c'est pour ça la justice que je fais
ce métier soyez au cœur de la justice
devenez surveillant
[Musique]
pénitentiaire bonjour à tous merci de
nous retrouver en direct sur public
sénna pour suivre dans quelques instants
la CL Clure du 19e congrès des régions
de France qui se tient cette année à
saint-malot en Bretagne et c'est
Élisabeth borne la première ministre qui
va venir prononcer ce discours de
clôture dans quelques instants on le
suivra en direct ainsi que les discours
qui précèdent dont celui de Carole Delga
la présidente de région de France et
celui de Gérard Larcher le président du
Sénat également présent du côté de
saint-malot on va regarder ce qui se
passe en direct à saint-malot puisque
c'est actuellement la plinière de
territoires Unis vous le savez c'est ce
qui regroupe les tris associations de
région les départements les ma et les
régions c'est Jean Dupont qui représente
l'Assemblée des départements de France
qui est actuellement en train de
s'exprimer et après cette plinière de
territoires unis et bien devrait
commencer cette séquence de clôture pour
nous accompagner Stéphane Vernet bonjour
Stéphane merci d'être avec nous Stéphane
qui dirige la rédaction parisienne de
est France et qui connaît donc la
Bretagne par cœur merci beaucoup
Stéphane d'être avec nous et Quentin
calm qu'on présente plus journaliste la
public s bonjour Quentin spécialiste des
concrets d'association d'élus voilà
consu ensemble conu sur Public Sénat
depuis plusieurs saisons ouis et
évidemment on va en parler alors je le
disais ellisabeth borne est attendue du
côté de saint-malot dans les prochaines
minutes c'est elle qui va conclure ce
congrès des région de France elle est
attendue la la première ministre
Stéphane d'abord un petit point on en
est où aujourd'hui des relations entre
État et région dans quel contexte arrive
la première ministre à Saint-Malo bah là
elle arrive dans un contexte d'annonce
forte qui concerne un certain nombre de
sujets essentiels pour les régions la
transition énergétique et écologique les
régions veulent être au cœur du
dispositif parce qu'elles sont
particulièrement bien placé pour le
faire il y a la problématique des
transports qui est directement liée j'ai
parlé l'énergie et puis il y a une
problématique générale de de de moyens
et de de responsabilité d'autonomie et
de décentralisation et tout ça est en
train de se combiner il y a des attentes
très fortes il y a un certain nombre de
dispositifs ou de promesses qui ont qui
ont qui avaient été faites qui ont pris
du retard et ce et cetera il y a quand
même pas mal de choses à à sold et je
pense que en fait les représentants des
régions et les représentants de l'État
ont beaucoup à se se dire au cours de
ces deux jours ça a déjà commencé il y a
eu un premier comité état région des
mobilités entre Clément baun et et les
présidents de région à H clos hier on
touche à les sujets essentiels et les
sujets qui vont concerner des montants
d'investissement assez pharaonique au
moment même où l'État présente un budget
à nouveau en déficit de manière très
spectaculaire avec un niveau
d'endettement délirant donc je trouve
que là on est la croisée des chemins
tout ce tout tout se cristallise en ce
moment et on va avoir évidemment
l'occasion de revenir sur ces questions
budgétaires Quentin comment ça se passe
en ce moment entre l'État et les régions
non effectivement le dialogue est
compliqué il a il a été depuis le début
du du premier quinquen d'Emmanuel Macron
les corps intermédiaires dont les
collectivités locales on l'impression
que effectivement ça ne communique pas
entre l'exécutif et et eux mais c'est
vrai qu'on avait vu une séquence des
congrès l'année dernière notamment à
Vichy à les régions et à agin les
départements à l'automne dernier où
Elisabeth borne qui était donc la
nouvelle Première ministre avait fait
des pas vers ses collectivités locales
qui avaient été apprécié on avait le
sentiment qu'il y avait une forme
d'apaisement qui s'était joué à
l'automne dernier et on a même retenu
cette phrase sur la décentralisation
d'éliisabeth born le 17 octobre 2022 au
Congrès des département elle avait dit
nous devons mener ensemble une nouvelle
étape pour une vraie décentralisation
alors elle y avait mis beaucoup beaucoup
de conditions et on va y revenir mais on
voit qu'elle refait un pas vers une
demande forte de toutes les strates des
collectivités locales qui est de nouveau
pouvoir de nouvelles formes de
décentralisation une vraie forme de
décentralisation et pas des mesurettes
comme on a eu selon eux avec les lois
3DS et cetera mais une quelque chose de
de fort et donc c'est versela maintenant
vers la concrétisation de ce signal fort
de décentralisation qu'on attend des
annonces sachant qu'il y a eu la réforme
des retraites et ensuite les 100 jours
qui ont complètement bloqué tous ces
sujet institutionnel il y a eu comme
cela le pouvoir exécutif qui a été
pétrifié sur ces sujets pendant pendant
tout le début de l'année 2023 donc on
voit que la séquence qui s'our avec ces
congrès qui reprennent c'est l'occasion
d'ouvrir une une une une page sur les
institutions en France qui est qui est
importé et qui est attendu aussi dans
les départements dans les régions et on
va voir ce qu'attend Carole LGA qui est
la présidente de région de France du
discours d'Élisabeth borne elle était ce
matin l'invité de notre matinale depuis
saint-malot on lui a posé la question de
savoir ce qu'elle attend de la première
ministre qui doit venir conclure leur
congrès ce matin qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de la première ministre mais
nous attendons tout d'abord qu'elle
puisse enfin comprendre qu'elle a tout
intérêt à à avoir un travail en commun
entre l'État et les régions pour
atteindre les objectifs de la
planification écologique pour atteindre
les objectifs de mobilité qui soit moins
cher qui soit plus décarboné pour
atteindre les objectifs de souveraineté
industrielle l'État et et les régions
doivent travailler ensemble et donc
l'État a besoin de nous comme nous nous
avons besoin de l'État et donc c'est un
message de faire confiance aux
régions les régions elles ont besoin de
confiance et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
ce qu'on entend he depuis le début du
premier quinquenat d'Emmanuel Macron de
la part des des collectivités Stéphane
elle demande à l'état de leur faire
confiance oui alors elle demande à
l'état de de leur faire confiance tout à
fait ça c'est pas nouveau ça fait un
petit moment que ça dure et c'est un
c'est c'est le nœud du problème il y'y a
pas que ça il y a autre chose c'estd que
il y a des annonces qui sont faites il y
a une volonté de travailler ensemble qui
est qui est manifesté donc tout le monde
s'en félicite sauf que ça n'avance pas
entre le les mots et les actes il y a
yatus qui pose problème je je sur le la
la question du du ferroviaire qui est
essentiel pour les régions l'année
dernière à Vichi Caro LGA dit elle elle
tire la sonette d'alarme en disant il
faut investir 100 milliards d'euros dans
le réseau ferroviaire d'ici 10 ans sinon
la moitié des lignes de ce pays vont
fermer en fait le il a fallu attendre
plusieurs mois pour avoir une réponse
sur un un plan transport et cetera mais
qui dit quoi qui dit que l'État va
doubler ses investissements on on sera à
4 milliards d'euros d'investissements
dans les infrastructure par an d'ici
2027 c'est super mais entre la demande
qui est 100 milliards pour 10 ans et la
réponse qui est en réalité 100 milliards
sur 17 ans il y a un il y a un premier
problème pendant ce temps-là tout le
tout le tout le dialogue qui devait se
faire autour du des contrats de plan
ettat région a pris quasiment un an de
retard c'està-dire que pendant que le
l'état préparé son plan sur le les
transports et les mobilités en fait le
les négociations ont été suspendues et
on revient à Saint-Malo avec la même
demande remise sur la table en disant
vous nous avez promis plein d'argent
c'est super mais pour l'instant on n pas
touché un radis et ça démarre pas pareil
avec la question de la transition
écologique la on voit qu'elle est au
cœur des débats aujourd'hui elle est
fondamentale je vous signale que le le
la la loi de programmation pluriannuelle
sur l'énergie aurait dû être prise au
plus tard au mois de juillet elle existe
toujours pas et en fait si vous voulez
il y a les déclarations les annonces
mais dans le concret un il y a du retard
et et il y a il y a les les objectifs ou
les moyens qui sont qui suivent qui sont
mis sur la table ne correspondent pas
aux besoins et donc là je pense que il y
a un petit y a un certain nombre de
réglages qui seront nécessaires qui sont
en train de se jouer en coulisse à à à
saint-malot mais au-delà des des
promesses et des bonnes des grandes
déclarations d'intention il faut que
l'état donne des gages pour entretenir
et restaurer cette confiance on parlait
de territoires Unis puisque en ce moment
hein c'est la réunion de territoire Unis
qui est qui est en cours à Saint-Malo au
Congrès avant la dernière séquence sur
les discours territoire uni pour rappel
hein c'est le rassemblement de de toutes
ces strates he les départements les
régions et les maires qui s'étaient
coalisés en 2018 pour répondre justement
à cette défiance et et pour mettre la
pression comme cela à Emmanuel Macron
face à une série d'annonces à l'époque
qui qui était défavorable à tous ces
échelons de de de des collectivités
locales et on voit qu'ils sont encore
réunis on est en 2023 et pour mettre
toujours la même pression il continue à
avoir cette réunion avant les discours
pour bien montrer que ils sont toujours
là les départements les régions les
maires à se parler pour essayer de faire
pression et peser dans ce dialogue parce
qu'effectivement ça n'avance pas ou en
tout cas ça n'avance pas suffisamment
rapidement à leurs yeux dans
effectivement le fait de de déléguer
enfin de nouvelles responsabilités et
bien entendu les financements qui vont
avec les leviers de financement et c'est
plutôt même le contraire qu'on a vu he
pour l'instant sur sur toutes les les
annonces budgétaires de même depuis
l'année dernière la CVAE encore supprimé
pour les départements on avait vu la
taxe d'habitation encore avant on voit
que la question budgétaire elle reste un
nud du du problème depuis depuis le
début du premier qu canmanuel Macon et
puis sur ce sujet éminidemment sensible
il y a la maladresse du président de la
République dans son l'interview qui
qu'il a accordé à TF1 et France 2
dimanche soir alors ça concerne pas les
régions mais quand il quand il met un
coup de pression sur les collectivités
en disant les gens voient leur taxe
foncière exploser c'est la c'est la
c'est la faute des communes c'est
scandaleux joue pas le jeu la faute du
gouvernement le vous avez vous avez les
maires de France qui enfin qui s'arrache
les cheveux quoi c'est-à-dire que le le
le chef de l'État oublie juste de dire
que les bases donc de de cette taxe qui
sont de dans de de la responsabilité de
l'État ont augmenté de 7 % cette année
donc il y a il y a un très grand nombre
de communes qui n touche pas à leur base
mais dont les administrés voient leur
leur taxe foncière augmenter et c'est
pas du tout la faute des mères C'est la
faute c'est la c'est la faute de c'est
la responsabilité directe de de de
l'État donc on est toujours encore dans
ce dans cette espèce de relation je
t'aime moi non plus et cetera on a
besoin les uns des autres il faut
restaurer la confiance mais en fait ils
sont ils sont en train de se mettre des
coups de taquet d'un côté comme de
l'autre dès qu'ils en ont l'occasion
pour des raisons de politique
politicienne et c'est pas comme ça qu'on
c'est pas comme ça qu'on avance encore
une fois sur du concret là il y a un
certain nombre de dossiers qui sont en
gestation depuis trop longtemps et qui
au-delà des mots doivent aboutir assez
rapidement il a du mal à parler aux élus
locaux Emmanuel Macron Quentin oui tout
à fait effectivement mais mais
effectivement ça ça rejoint cette cette
critique sur les corps intermédiairees
et et ça on na pas le sentiment qui une
énorme évolution de méthode même depuis
depuis sa réélection 2022 c'estàd qu'
intermédiaire que ce soit les syndicats
qui représentent les les salariés que ce
soit les élus locaux que ce soit même
les parlementaires le Parlement dimanche
soir il s'exprime le soir de l'élection
sénatoriale euh qu'est-ce que ça dit de
ce qu'il a voilà ce qu'il attend de du
Sénat lorsquil il est concentré sur sur
sa propre prise de parole alors que
l'élection se joue en même temps au
Sénat voilà ce sont des petites choses
comme cela mais où effectivement on voit
que bah le le ressort est distendu on a
du mal à à voir comment est-ce que ça
peut se rapprocher avec avec ces
collectivités ces corps intermédiaires
ouais alors que juste un mot de ce qui
se passe du côté de saint-malot hein la
plainère de territoire uni vient de
prendre fin euh la prochaine séquence
c'est c'est la séquence de clôture avec
donc quatre discours à suivre celui de
Louis chengérard le président de la
Région Bretagne qui accueille donc ce
congrès le discours de Carole Delga la
présidente de région de France celui de
Gérard Larchet le président du Sénat et
celui de la première- ministre
ellisabeth born parmi les sujets sur
lesquels est attendu ellisabeth borne
alors qu'on entend l'alarme au Sénat
c'est les sujets de la question
financière Stéphane évidemment parce que
les régions ell disent ben là on a une
partie de la TVA certes mais c'est pas
suffisant ça nous permet pas de
compenser nosûs nos dépenses ben
évidemment et puis le la enfors ça c'est
le serpent de mer l'argent c'est le nerf
de la guerre ça fait longtemps que les
demandes sont importantes en en la
matière et on voit bien que le enfin la
réalité c'est qu'on vit dans un pays qui
est à l'os au côté du côté des finances
et que et que dans les les efforts de
d'économie qui vont être demandés par
l'État aux uns et aux autres je vous
inter juste 2 seconde Stéphane on voit
l'arrivée d'Élisabeth born en direct
dans cette salle à saint-malot la
première ministre qui fait donc son
entrée dans ce congrès des régions de
France pour la séquence de clôture qui
devrait débuter dans quelques minutes
pardon Stéphane allezy non je disais en
fait on est d'un point de vue du point
de vue de l'argent on a on a on a un
gros problème on a un mur
d'investissement qui arrive notamment et
qui est lié à la transition écologique
dans le ferroviaire notamment c'est
énorme mais dans le ferroviaire dans
l'énergie dans toutes sortes de de enfin
voilà th mais bon enfin on l'a bien vu
avec la présentation du du budget de
l'État il y a il y a des besoins énormes
des besoins investissement énorme et le
problème c'est qu'on est dans un on vit
dans un pays qui est qui croule sous les
dettes on atteint un niveau
d'endettement qui est littéralement
délirant donc le le le on a on n pas de
on a plus de marge de manœuvre on n pas
d'argent pour faire face à ces besoins
et donc il y a une il y a aussi la
volonté d'essayer de grappiller des sous
à droite à gauche et donc vous avez les
collectivités locales toutes et les
régions en particulier qui disent nous
on veut être des acteurs majeurs de ces
développements de ces investissements on
peut faire on sait faire c'est dans nos
compé c'est dans notre domaine mais on a
besoin de moyens pour y arriver et les
moyens on en a plus en face vous avez
plutôt un état qui va chercher à dire
bah comme on a besoin d'économiser on va
on va encore chercher à renier sur les
moyens donnés aux collectivités et puis
bah faites participer faites des
investissement mais débrouillez-vous
avec vos propres ressources sauf
qu'elles n ont plus ou en tout cas pas à
la hauteur des enjeux et des besoins et
ça a participer à de la brouille toutes
ces questions budgétaire et financière
lorsque le chef de éat en 2017 lance la
conférence des territoires qui devait
être un grand rendez-vous pour renouer
le dialogue on se rend compte dès
l'année suivante que ça capote
complètement il y a 450 millions
d'économies qui sont demandé aux régions
en 2018 c'est et c'est même annoncé
pendant leur congrès qui se tenait à
l'époque à Orléan alors forcément les
régions ont été ont été très très
mécontentes de cet effort qu'on leur
demandait à ce moment-là et c'est ce qui
fait qu'elles ne se rendront même pas
les collectivités locales à la troisè
rencontre de la conférence des
territoires et et ça a participé
effectivement de cette brouille entre
l'exécutif et les régions on va juste
regarder ce qui se passe du côté de
Saint-Malo c'est la séquence outremaire
qui commence c'est la séquence qui va
précéder la séance de clôture puisqu'on
parlait de la question des des dotations
là encore on a posé ce matin la question
à Carole Delga la présidente de région
de France savoir est-ce qu'elle
demandait des moyens à Elisabeth borne
on l'écoute nous demandons d'avoir en
fait des dotations qui soient au même
niveau euh que euh l'année dernière
parce que dans ce projet de la finance
il y a une baisse de près de 150
millions d'euros et ensuite euh nous
demandons qu'il y ait une compensation
euh de l'inflation et c'est pourquoi
nous avons demandé plus de 350 millions
qui seront fléchés vers des
investissements divers que ça soit pour
la rénovation énergétique des lycées des
bâtiments ou que ça soit pour les milité
voilà Carole Delga qui le qui le dit
Stéphane elle a besoin de moyens oui
c'est ça et qui soit fléché sur des sur
des sur des besoins spécifiques elle
évoque la rénovation énergétique des
lycées les mobilités mais regardez ce
qui se passe en face c'est-à-dire que
dans le même temps dans le cas de la
planification écologique on a l'annonce
de du gouvernement par exemple de la
mise en place d'un passe rail pour l'été
49 € pour pouvoir comme comme ça se fait
en Allemagne c'est super mais qui va
payer
qui va payer avec quel argent c'est M
chose ça s'est annoncé sans que les
régions a été mises au courant à la fin
de l'été voilà et les régions qui vont
être qui sont organisatrices des
transports sur le territoire donc est-ce
que on annonce comme ça en grande pompe
quelque chose sans avoir même prévenu
les autorités régionales qui sont en
charge de de ce passe ça ça interroge
même récemment quoi ouais alors pendant
que les présidents de région sont réunis
à à saint-malot il y a un président de
région qui n'est pas là entre autres
c'est Gilles Siméon puisqu'il accueille
en ce moment même Emmanuel Macron à
l'Assemblée de Corse le chef de l'État
qui doit prononcer àure où on se parle
un discours devant les élus Quentin les
élus cors qui attend beaucoup du chef de
l'État sur la question de l'autonomie
bien sûr c'est une question aussi que
voilà qui est en suspens depuis plus
d'un an puisque on se rappelle B de ces
de ces violences qui avait voilà
émailler l'île de beauté en mars 2022
euh euh effectivement les Corses qui
attendent impatiemment maintenant de
savoir quelle est la décision euh qu'a
pris l'exécutif donc effectivement
Emmanuel Macron se RA en Corse on verra
quelle est l'intensité qu'il souhaite
donner à son discours et quel est le
niveau d'autonomie qu'il accepte de
donner aux élus cors et effectivement
les Corses les élus corses les élus
nationalistes qui eux ont une liste
effectivement de de demandes très
précises sur un statut de résident pour
les cors aussi sur la coofficialité de
la langue corse ou encore et bien la
reconnaissance d'un peuple Corse dans la
Constitution ce sont des demandes sur
lesquelles ils se sont mis d'accord au
sein de l'Assemblée de Corse mais que
l'on voit mal le chef de l'État accepté
dans leur entièreté qu'on verra
effectivement le niveau de précision
qu'il donne effectivement à son message
aujourd'hui ouais on va voir on va
essayer d'avoir des extraits entre ce
discours d'Emmanuel Macron Stéphane qui
est évidemment à attendu hein et là
aussi au-delà de l'accord c'est jusqu'où
le chef de l'État est prêt à aller dans
la décentralisation
ouais puis sur les sur les sur les
demandes que que vient de
de qui viennent d'être évoqué en fait il
y a quand même un problème c'est-à-dire
que on peut se dire tiens voilà sur le
la coofficialité de la langue la
reconnaissance d'un peuple Corse dans la
Constitution c'est symbolique bah oui
sauf que ça pour ça pour pour y arriver
il faudrait changer la constitution on a
vu que c'était un exercice un peu
compliqué c'est difficile de toucher à
la Constitution dans ce pays enfin
surtout au cours des dernières années on
a on a essayé ça c'est c'est ça ce n'est
pas si facile et puis après vous avez
créé des précédent il y a pas clickorse
en France vous avez les Bretons les
Alsaciens les Basques et cetera donc
voilà on va écouter les Bretons et ouis
et le stat et le statut de résident est
un est un est est un sujet qui fâche à
mon avis on parler évidemment mais la
séquence de clôture a commencé c'est le
X chîngérard le président de la Région
Bretagne qui accueille donc ce congrès
des régions cette année qui a pris la
par MAM Messieurs les Présidents des
céser monsieur le prés président du césr
de France chers collègues céser de
Bretagne aussi chers tous merci d'être
ici à saint-malot vous dire d'abord à
quel point la Bretagne est heureuse de
vous y accueillir de vous y accueillir
monsieur le Maire dans cette ville si
emblématique de la Bretagne dans ce
Palais du Grand Large magnifique je
remercie toutes celles et ceux qui ont
permis l'organisation de ce congrès les
équipes de région de France bien entendu
et ma très chère team Bretagne merci
beaucoup pour cette organisation
ce
congrès ce congrès est pour moi
l'occasion de rendre un hommage un
hommage à cette extrémité occidentale ce
bout d'Europe et ces ces constellations
d'île dans l'océan cette terre de
tradition furieusement ancrée dans la
modernité regorgeant de paysages aimés
qui façonnent les imaginaires et ancre
les appartenances qui parle plusieurs
langues territoire de liberté et
d'humanité solidement enraciné et
ouvertes sur le monde la France puisque
oui je parle de la France la France est
une et multiple comme l'Europe dont elle
être une partie de l'ensemble comme ces
régions qui la composent et dessinent un
tout ces régions elles-mêmes sont fait
de départements imbriquet
d'agglomération constellés de communes
parsemés de quartiers
chacune ensemble et chaque sous-ensemble
revendiquant singularité identité
spécificité rien d'extraordinaire je ne
connais pas de pays qui soit un bloc
d'une homogénéité absolue et
heureusement et les organisations
politiques sont toutes aussi varié la
France comme chaque région qui la
compose a son histoire son histoire qui
a conduit l'organisation territoriale
que nous que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas en un jour
j'espère qu'elle n'est pas finie et elle
n'a pas vécu sans heure ni douleur
rappelons-nous le chemin parcouru depuis
les années 50 rappelons-nous du général
de Gaulle en 1969 àimpère à parlant à
l'époque de ce que devait être les
régions un cadre nouveau de l'initiative
du conseil et de l'action pour ce qui
touche localement la vie pratique de la
nation deux vagues de régionalisation
ensuite un redécoupage on trouvera
toujours à redire toujours à penser
qu'on pe peut faire mieux toujours à
penser qu'on pourrait redécouper
pourrait même penser à gagner quelques
départements voisins cher Christel tant
la région Bretagne déborde de son
territoire historique force de constater
que les régions comme entités politiques
et administrativ en dépit des écueils et
des moyens limités c'est une réussite et
je vous donnerai trois exemples
les TER d'abord dans ce moment où on
parle tant de mobilité les TER et avec
les TER tous les services de car que
nous organisons et en Bretagne les
bateaux C TER ils sont une réussite et
ils font voyager des millions de
Françaises et de français tous les jour
les régions ont su investir pendant des
années et des années sans fiscalité
dédiée sur ce sujet dans leur train dans
leur car dans leur service publics de
transport mais aussi dans les
infrastructures dans les infrastructures
qui au passage ne leur appartiennent pas
mais qui permettent de proposer un moyen
de transport souvent décarboné au
bénéfice des habitantes et des habitants
c'est désormais un meilleur service
public de transport pour les citoyens
nous avons tous gagné dans cette
opération et nous pourrions encore aller
plus loin nous savons qu'un accord a été
trouvé avec Île-de-France sur le
financement des mobilités nous en avons
parlé longuement avec Clément bon hier
qui a tenu une longue réunion avec tous
les présidents de région et nous l'en
avons remercié et comme il s'y est
engagé hier nous devons avancer avant
avec les autres régions que
l'île-de-fance pour nous engager ainsi
dans un travail collectif qui doit
aboutir je le souhaite rapidement 2è
exemple les lycées les lycées alors
qu'un scandale secou le Royaume-Uni
depuis la rentrée du fait de l'état
déplorable de leur baâtiment scolaire
nous pouvons nous réjouir de ce côté de
la Manche car confiés aux régions pour
les lycées au départements pour les
collèges aux communes pour les écoles
les bâtiments qui accueillent nos
enfants font l'objet de beaucoup de
soins
ce ne sont pas que des murs c'est un
lieu de vie pour notre jeunesse c'est
comme l'a si bien dit
monaozouf le cœur de l'entreprise
républicaine le lieu où on professe la
perfectibilité indéfinie et la prise de
l'homme sur son destin aussi j'aurai le
plaisir l'honneur la fierté demain
d'inaugurer un nouveau lycée à pleumel
le lycée
monaosouf je vous invite à découvrir
cette femme à la lire cette bretonne
furieusement
républicaine cette bretonne furieusement
républicaine est si ancrée dans notre
histoire notre identité et nos racines
un Bouffet de jeunesse et d'énergie que
de la lire et beaucoup d'enthousiasme
pour l'avenir troème exemple enfin les
canaux exemple bien breton bien breton
car ici en Bretagne nous avons récupéré
les canaux par un texte de
décentralisation c'est un patrimoine
militaire un patrimoine industriel et et
depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années ce
sont les services de la Région qui gèent
ces canaux avec Briot et au service
finalement de l'aménagement du
territoire avec le développement de
mobilité douce le développement du
tourisme fluvestre la protection de la
biodiversité le réservoir d'eau douce
qu'il constitue bref un patrimoine
fluvial qui bénéficie aujourd'hui d'un
second souffle comme les les territoires
qu'il traverse du Centre Bretagne
notamment qui bénéficie ainsi d'une
nouvelle énergie insufflée avec tous les
liens que nous son avec les autres
collectivités et partenaires locaux vous
avez dit l'année dernière cher Carole
madame la Première ministre a repris le
terme ensite que nous étions ensemble
une équipe France je partage pleinement
cette vision cette ensemble toutes les
collectivités ensemble quel que soit
leur niveau qui composent l'équipe de
France de la mre de village au président
de la République madame la Première
ministre vous avez rappelé l'année
dernière à Vichy qu'il fallait je vous
cite tenir compte des spécificités de
chaque territoire de leur diversité de
leurs atouts et de leur fragilité et
d'ajouter qu'il fallait donner des
marges manœuvre aux uns et aux autres et
nous faire confiance pour expérimenter
et innover avec une véritable lisibilité
sur les moyens à louer je souscris bien
entendu et je vous rejoins totalement et
je suis d'accord avec vous seul le
collectif permettra de réussir seul le
collectif nous permettra de réussir
faut-il qu'il soit bien organisé ce
collectif et bien armé pour relever les
défis et mener les
combats une troupe nombreuse mais
désorganisée et mal équipée
n'enchaînerait que déconvenu et débacle
jusqu'à la défaite or les défis les
défis que nous avons face à nous les
défis auquels fait face la France la
touche et la dépasse à la fois l'action
contre le dérèglement climatique tant au
niveau de l'adaptation qu'au niveau de
la lutte contre ce changement climatique
nous devons fermer la parenthèse du
fossil et ce sera un combat que nous
devrons tous assumer ensemble l'enjeu de
la sécurité mondiale compromise
notamment par les guerres qui la guerre
qui fit rage à nos portes sur le
continent européen et je me souviens
fortement avec beaucoup d'émotions les
mots l'année dernière Avichi de
l'ambassadeur
d'Ukraine enfin et les évolutions des
deux périls que j'ai cité précédemment
détermineront aussi l'ampleur de ce
troisième défi la gestion des migrations
permettez-moi de préciser la gestion
sans naïveté mais empreinte d'humanité
des migrations d'hommes de femmes et
d'enfants ces défis nous devons nous y
faisons déjà face et nous devrons encore
tous y faire face individuellement et
collectivement qu'on soit Maloin qu'on
soit breton qu'on soit français qu'on
soit européen et finalement qu'on soit
tout cela à la fois
Corse ou martiniicaaise occitan ou des
haute- France parisienne ou de
Castelmoron d'albray nous devons tous
regarder dans la même direction mais de
quelqu territoire que l'on vienne face à
ces défis nous devons toujours conserver
une seule et même boussole le sens de la
République et les valeurs de la
démocratie et c'est ici et c'est ici
certainement le plus grand des combats
que nous avons amené ensemble tous
ensemble ce sujet de l'équipe France
c'est ce sujet de la démocratie nous
l'observons il y a un risque de fissure
de nos fondations mêmes à
l'international nous voyons les
populations vivants dans des démocraties
se réduire plus de la moitié de
l'humanité vit sous un régime qui n'est
pas une démocratie aujourd'hui plus
d'une personne sur trois dans le monde
vit dans un régime autoritaire ou une
dictature et au National nous voyons les
extrêmes gagnés du terrain les
contestations se radicaliser le dialogue
démocratique
indifféré en Bretagne aussi pourtant
réputé région ouverte et accueillante
qui a toujours connu une faible
représentation de l'extrême droite nous
nous retrouvons confrontés à une
multiplication d'actes aineux et
hostiles aux valeurs d'ouverture et de
solidarité que nous défendons ici les
attaques contre les symboles de la
République ne datent pas d'hier mais
aujourd'hui ce ne sont plus seulement
les symboles ce sont les élus de la
République qui sont attaqués violemment
menaçant leur vie je pense je pense à
jeaniv Rolland de Calac je pense tout
autant à Yannick morz puis à Dorothé
PASC de saint-brévin- Lespin ainsi qu'à
Vincent jean-brin de l'aller rose il y a
une violence sociale latente qui croit
avec la montée de l'inflation de
l'exclusion de la volonté de faire des
bouces émissaires ceux qui seraient
responsable de tous nos mots à tous les
niveaux de la société l'angoisse du
déclassement de la paupérisation et la
peur la peur ce sentiment chez certains
de nos concitoyens qu'il faut casser le
système et que nous élus nous qui
assumons ces responsabilités au com bien
importante pour l'avenir de notre pays
nous ne servverions plus à rien aussi il
faut renouveler le contrat social pour
cela il faut un Pact entre nous
gouvernement et collectivité chacun a
son poste en ordre de bataille sans nier
nos différences chacun dans ses champs
de compétences doté des moyens qui lui
permett d'être vérit véritablement
opérationnel et efficace bref autonome
la politique en circuit court non pas
juste pour son pour son précarré au
bénéfice bien entendu de l'ensemble les
grands défis supranationaux appelant une
réponse nationale forte de la puissance
d'un collectif soudé uni par des
objectifs communs les problématiques
locales appelant des solutions adaptées
au plus près des besoins taillé sur
mesure par les autorités de
proximité aussi que tous les échelons de
pouvoir ne promettent pas tout à tous
car nous ne ferions que renforcer la
défiance à l'égard de la puissance
publique chacun a son poste je le disais
dans un esprit de soutien et de
coopération c'est un changement d'état
d'esprit réellement profond qu'il nous
faut mettre en œuvre l'efficacité passe
par le travail en commun y compris au
passage pour les agences de l'État vous
l'avez également dit madame la Première
ministre pour être efficace nous devons
associer toutes les collectivités le
cloisonnement serait une erreur c'est
dans cet esprit que la Bretagne a
travaillé un socle de proposition pour
une république des territoires au
fondement démocratique fortifié que je
vous ai confié monsieur le Président du
Sénat je vous en ai aussi adresser une
copie lorsque comme je le fais à chaque
fois que le Conseil régional la Bretagne
émet des avis des remarques des
propositions pour l'avenir de la
Bretagne mais aussi pour l'avenir de la
République ces propositions I sont issu
d'un dialogue transpartisan que je salue
aujourd'hui car plusieurs des
conseillers régionaux de tous les bancs
sont dans la salle ce travail est le
fruit des leç son tirer des expériences
de la Décentralisation et des tentatives
de déconcentration des récentes
décennies ainsi sans dévoiler
l'entièreté du rapport ces propositions
visent à sécurit sécuriser
l'atterrissage de politique nationale à
l'échelon régional en Bretagne ou
ailleurs car je le dis nous n'avons pas
l'exclusivité de ces réflexions ainsi il
a été identifié que notamment ici en
Bretagne mais je sais que Christal
moranet le vit tout autant que moi à
l'échelle régionale la concertation
fonctionne je pense notamment à la
conférence régionale ma et littoral
organisée par la région elle a été utile
pour permettre l'implantation des
éolienne en mer à Saint-Brieux je sais
pas si vous les avez vu mais on les voit
des étages ici ou des remparts et ces
éoliennes je le rappelle c'est 14 ans de
travail 14 ans de travail qui ne se mène
pas sans une concertation et un travail
approfondi à assumé par les élus locaux
si j'en parle ici c'est parce que je
pense que nous en avons furieusement
besoin pour demain et si autorisé la
concertation n'appelle pas de moyens
supplémentaires il faut bien entendu à
chaque fois et régulièrement le
confirmer et le renforcer au passage
puisque je parle de la mer permettez-moi
de vous dire que nous devons tous
ensemble nous occuper du sujet de la
pêche de nos marins pêcheurs qui marin
pêcheurs européens sont les plus
puissants défenseurs de la biodiversité
que nous avons dans le monde par rapport
aux autres pêches et notamment les
pêches issues de pays lointains et de
bateaux usin avec à bord des hommes et
des femmes qui malheureusement
pourraient être qualifié d'esclaves nous
avons besoin de travailler cela depuis
Bruxelles jusqu'aux collectivités nous
nous entretenons régulièrement avec
Hervé Berville je sais que d'autres
réunions auront lieu dans la journée et
c'est indispensable poureton que je suis
je veux bien entendu protéger les
dauphins mais je veux aussi protéger mes
pêcheur par
ailleursur d'illeurs certains
dispositifs fiscaux gagneraient à être
rénovés je me permets ici de vous dire
que nous avions travaillé avec Julien
Normandie et Édouard Philippe pour
inventer le pinal breton ce pinal breton
c'est pas plus d'argent pour la Bretagne
c'est juste nous autoriser à répartir
différemment en Bretagne des outils
fiscaux mis en place pour favoriser le
développement du logement ça a bien
fonctionné cela va s'éteindre avec le
Pinel mais vu la situation de logement
nous pouvons inventer d'autres choses je
l'ai dit au ministre béu je dis dit à
toutes celles et ceux qui sont
disponibles nous en avions parlé aussi
madame la Première ministre nous sommes
prêts à expérimenter à inventer et à
faire en sorte que les élus à l'échelle
régionale je dis bien les élus des
collectivités à l'échelle régionale
prennent leur part pour assumer leur
responsabilités et ainsi mettre en œuvre
un réel vecteur
d'efficacité même chose sur les zonages
même chose sur les zonages nous sommes
ici à samalo le maire de samintalo a pu
obtenir une expérimentation pour réguler
le Airbnb c'est indispensable et bravo
pour le courage et l'énergie que le
maire et son équipe mettent dans cette
opération mais il conviendrait d'obtenir
que les maires le bloc communal puisse
assumer ses responsensabilité sur ce
point et non pas de le faire par un
pilotage d'un conseiller à Paris sur son
tableur Excel ou par l'entre gens de
quelques parlementaires toujours
courageux ici en Bretagne quels que
soient les bans pour obtenir que telle
ou telle commune soit mise dans telle ou
telle liste ça c'est furieusement
ringard et il faut passer à autre chose
d'autres dispositifs d'autres
compétences appelleront en revanche
davantage de moyens le sujet des moyens
nécessairire mais avant de parler du
sujet des moyens il s'agit d'abord pour
nous tous d'opérer des arbitrages dans
nos choix de politique publique sport de
combat régulier de tous les élus qui
sont ici présents et d'identifier les
gains et marges de manœuvre dans nos
organisations des collectivités jusqu'à
l'état j'ai envie de dire jusqu'à
l'Europe cette exigence d'efficacité
doit se retrouver à tous les niveaux et
nécessairement cela posera bien entendu
le sujet de la fiscalité ce suja ce
sujet devra être reposé une rénovation
est nécessaire à l'échelle européenne
comme à l'échelle locale face au murs de
sujets qui sont face à nous il faut donc
avoir le courage d'ouvrir le débat ce
débat sur la fiscalité dépasse l'ASP
strict au sensu financier même l'aspect
strict au sensu du Congrès des régions
mais c'est un débat sur la
responsabilité sur la confiance qu'il
convient de mener et d'échanger à tous
les niveaux et dans tous les territoires
de la République sortons donc chers
collègues enfin de la foire au vanité et
aux prétentions et faisons front commun
faisons front commun car la question
n'est plus de savoir aujourd'hui qui
gagne quoi mais comment s'organiser pour
donner du souffle à notre démocratie
nous avons une responsabilité qui va
au-delà de l'immédiate gestionnaire nous
devons redonner du sens à l'expérience
républicaine pour les femmes et les
hommes qui habitent dans nos régions
pour les femmes et les hommes qui
habitent dans nos villes et dans nos
campagnes qui habitent notre pays et qui
peuvent s'en sentir exclus ce sont bien
eux les destinataires de l'action
publique ce sont bien eux les
bénéficiaires des services publics et
les dépositaires de l'intérêt général
nos décisions nos actions au de sens que
parce qu'elles se traduisent dans leur
quotidien dans leur vie pour la jeunesse
aussi pour cette jeunesse qui je
l'espère nous remplacera et ils ont des
rêves plein les poches un pays une
région ce n'est pas qu'un projet sur un
papier c'est aussi une volonté une
volonté à mettre en œuvre bevette Brez
vive la république et vive la france
merci merci beaucoup merci loï Chan
Gérard président de la Région Bretagne
pour ce premier
propos j'invite à présent à venir devant
vous Carole Delga présidente de région
de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
France
madame la Première ministre cher
Élisabeth monsieur le Président du Sénat
cher Gérard Larcher mesdames et
messieurs les ministres Mesdames et
Messieurs les
parlementaires monsieur le Président des
céser de France cher Dominique Monsieur
le Maire de semmalo cher Gill merci pour
ton remarquable
accueil merci d'être ici à à saintmalot
monsieur le Président de la Région
Bretagne cher log merci beaucoup pour
l'ensemble de l'organisation de de cet
événement merci à tes équipes puis merci
également pour ces perspectives que tu
viens de tracer nous vous saluant toutes
et tous et bien sûr j'associe le
président délégué Renaud Muselier nous
saluons nos chers collègues donc
présidentes et présidents de région de
France Mesdames et Messieurs les élus
Mesdames et Messieurs chers partenaires
Mesdames et Messieurs les agents des
collectivités territoriales vous qui
êtes chaque jour le visage de nos
régions et la force des services
publics ici à
semmot cher Gill Lurton nous sommes
saisis à la fois par la force de vos
remparts mais aussi par la fragilité de
nos constructions devant la puissance de
la mer de par bien sûr les risques de
submersion
conjuguer des exigences qui semblent
contraires pour certains conjuguer les
exigences sociales économiques
environnemental c'est notre quotidien
d'élu
local
alors madame la Première ministre je
vous lance un
défi un défi poussé par le souffle
breton et si vous ne faisiez confiance
et si nous formions un vrai tendem état
région pour atteindre nos objectifs
communs la planification écologique bien
sûr la souveraineté de notre pays
industrielle énergétique
alimentaire sanitaire la réduction des
inégalités par un savoir accessible à
tous et à un travail de valeur en terme
clair et si nous acceptions de
travailler de réellement travailler de
bâtir des projets des conjugaisons des
conciliation bref
apporter réellement des solutions pour
que le cœur des Français soit plus
heureux parce que c'est le thème de
notre congrès les régions au cœur des
solutions alors oui travaillons
travaillons ardemment donnons l'exemple
et le cap car c'est là que réside la
noblesse de nos mandats d'élus locaux
d'élus nationaux de présidents de région
et c'est dans l'action concrète que nous
réalisons les engagements que nous avons
pris de ant les électeurs
entre possible et impossible de lêre et
un état d'esprit c'est cette belle
citation que j'affectionne
particulièrement du général de Gaulle
dans ses Mémoires de guerre en fait il
dérivait le général de Gaulle un état
d'esprit et le souffle le souffle de
l'action qui nous anime tous et donc
aujourd'hui soyons sur le souffle le
souffle breton et sur cet appel et ce
défi de sa
Malo parce que rien nous est plus
difficile que de constater que notre
action est entravée souvent que notre
pouvoir d'agir est restreint au fond que
les libertés locales qui sont la réponse
à bien des problèmes de nos concitoyens
sont si souvent corcetés parfois
paralysés alors madame la Première
ministre chère Élisabeth je souhaite
vous remercier de votre présence cette
année encore parmi nous avec plusieurs
autres membres du gouvernement elle est
le symbole bien entendu de l'attention
sincère que vous portez aux régions et
donc madame la Première ministre au nom
des présidentes et des présidents des
régions de France je vous lance cet
appel de Saint Malo pour ce nouveau
souffle nous avons besoin de vous
entendre sur les sujets que nous
partageons car la situation de la France
de notre beau pays dans toutes ces
diversit est contrasté et
préoccupant au plan
économique la situation donne des signne
d'amélioration avec un taux de chômage à
7 % qui est une moyenne
nationale mais qui masque des disparités
territoriales très très fortes le nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi n'a jamais été
aussi faible depuis 2008 la France est
désormais le pays le plus attractif
d'Europe pour les investissements
étrangers nous en félicitons mais dans
le même temps le climat des affaires est
morose la crise de l'immobilier et du
logement et j'insiste sur cette crise du
logement nous en avons parlé au début de
l'été avec le président Larché cette
crise du logement monte
inexorablement nous avons aussi une
alerte sur la charge de la dette et puis
pour nos
concitoyens parce que il est nécessaire
d'être attentif aux Français et aux
Français et de ne pas rester dans des
comités restreints l'INC dresse cette
semaine le constat du recul des du moral
des ménages en France avec de fortes
préoccupations qui s'expriment sur
l'inflation sur la baisse du niveau de
vie les craintes concernant l'évolution
du chômage devant la hausse des taux
d'intérêt et les refus d'octroit des
prêts et puis nous voyons les
travailleurs devenir de plus en plus
pauvres et la précarité la misère
grandir ici ajoute le sentiment pour nos
concitoyens d'impuissance
ou de peur devant un mode un monde qui
se dérègle devant la sécheresse ou les
incendies de l'été devant les coupures
d'eau et j'ai une pensée particulière
pour
Mayotte ce territoire français qui
souffre je pense aussi au plan de
rationnement de l'énergie ces angoisses
trouvent un
dans les catastrophes naturelles qui ont
affecté les peuples de la Méditerranée
dans le retour de la guerre aux
frontières de l'Union européenne bien
sûr plein soutien au peuple ukrainien et
bien sûr nous pensons aussi au peuple
arménien il y a
[Applaudissements]
aussi il y a aussi et plus profondément
le creusement des inégalités le
sentiment de classe enfermé enfermé dans
leurs conditions sociales dans leurs
conditions territoriales
encagé dans leur territoire ces
expressions individuelles et collectifs
de défiance vis-à-vis des autorités
occupent l'actualité de l'information en
continu les relations entre les
individus se tendent l'autre devient un
étranger parfois même une menace ou un
adversaire alors nous devons réagir nous
devons créer du lien et puis bien
entendu on ne peut pas passer sous
silence les terribles phénomènes de
harcèlement à d'école les tragédies bien
sûr de suicide d'adolescents et je tiens
à saluer madame la Première ministre
votre mobilisation sur ce sujet et le
plan que vous avez annoncé
hier bref les Français sont dans une
situation de tension permanente devant
un
environnement international planétaire
anxiogène et une manière de faire de la
politique qu'ils ne comprennent
pas une politique de la parole mais de
la parole vide de sens avec des annonces
creuses et ou non suivi des faits ou des
paroles violentes agressives de
l'imveactive et à cette violence verbale
s'ajoute une réalité de vie dure parce
que nous n'oublions pas les fermetures
de services dans les hôpitaux au cours
de
l'été l'embouteillage sur la
réalisation de démarche administrative
le tout
numérique qui fait que certains se
sentent éloignés éloigné de tout je
parle aussi de l'éloignement physique et
la nécessité d'avoir des infrastructures
de
transport nous avons donc la nécessité
de donner une réponse de donner une
réponse alors ce nouveau souffle
concrètement peut-il se déployer avec de
la conviction tout d'abord avec des
convictions solidement ancrées loin des
des girouettes qui cèdent au vent avec
notre conviction celle de notre
responsabilité collective pour répondre
à ce contexte d'inquiétude travailler
ensemble pour les Français et nous les
présidents de la région nous l'avons
fait nous le faisons nous l'avons fait
lors de la crise du covid où nous étons
à côté de l'État pour soutenir nos
soignants avec la fourniture de matériel
de protection en organisant des
campagnes campagnes de dépistage ou en
aidant aussi fortement en partenariat
avec l'État les acteurs économiques qui
étaient fragilisés ou menacés je tiens à
le rappeler les régions ont augmenté de
2 milliards d'euros entre 2020 et 2022
le nombre le montant de leurs
investissements passtiant ainsi de 2020
à 2022 de 11 à 13
milliards 11 à 13 milliards pour
soutenir l'effort de l'État le plan de
relance qui était absolument
indispensable nous avons été les
partenaires les plus engagés parce que
nous avons les missions sur le
développement économique face à cette
vement exceptionnel il était nécessaire
d'avoir l'union sacrée et comment
comprendre la décru de nos recettes les
régions sont le seul échelon de
collectivité aujourd'hui qui n'a pas
retrouvé en 2022 ni en 2023 son niveau
d'épargne avant-crise ni sa capacité de
désendettement parce que cet
investissement il était indispensable au
côté de l'État nous l'avons fait et nous
voulons bien sûr continuer dans l'effet
ce n'est pas le constat auquel nous
sommes confrontés je ne vais citer que
quelques exemples ces dernières
semaines hier le projet de loi de
finances pour
2024 dotation de compensation de réforme
de la taxe professionnelle pour les
régions une baisse de 6,3 % 30 millions
d'euros en moins alors qu'elle ne
baissera que de 1 % pour les communes
1,3 pour les EPCI et 08 pour les
départements quelle est la
cohérence quelle est la justice je
pourrais également citer la compensation
de la perte de recette de 107 millions
d'euros dédié au financement de la
formation professionnelle et issu des
frais de gestion de la CVAE qui était
une compensation pérenne je vouslais
prouver l'année dernière madame la
Première ministre et de nouveau cette
année je vais devoir le prouver à que de
temps perdu ne soyons pas dans la
mesquinerie face à la faiblesse de
l'enjeu comparé à l'envergure du budget
de
l'État alors ligotter asphyxier les
régions quel intérêt alors que vous avez
besoin de nous pour que nous fassions
réussir la France ensemble parce que nos
succès seront vos succès parce que vos
succès seront nos succès nous sommes
présidentes et présidents de région
pleinement mobilisés nous sommes membres
de l'équipe France je vous l'ai déjà
indiqué je le Martelle oui au côté du
gouvernement le couple état région est
fondamental est un moteur indispensable
pour la réussite alors dans cette
période faisons pack faisons pack comme
rugby parce que c'est un ASI que la
France peut gagner d'autres exemples en
matière de transport quelle est la
traduction concrète de 100 milliards
d'euros d'investissement j'y reviendrai
quel est le sens des annonces non
concertés avec les régions sur le passe
national nous y sommes favorables bien
entendu avoir une politique tarifaire
mais travaillons en premier travaillons
avant de faire des annonces qui n'ont
pas eu le début d'une
réalité je voudrais
aussi juste rappeler si on parle des
mobilités ce qui est une réalité
fiscale quand un français fait fait un
plein dans sa voiture aujourd'hui c'est
quasiment 100 €. sur 100 € il y a 1
€ qui revient aux régions on est bien
loin du quart des taxes sur le carburant
qui reviendrait aux régions comme l'a
indiqué le président de la République
alors si le président de la République
veut nous donner un/4 des taxes pour le
budget des régions
banco un autre exemple parce que nous y
sommes toutes et tous particulièrement
engagés la planification écologique la
planification écologique elle est
fondamentale pour donner un espoir à nos
jeunes l chgard l'a bien rappelé
ces préoccupations elles sont vibrantes
dans la jeunesse et nous devons y
répondre et nous partageons la nécessité
du mix énergétique avec bien sûr la
sûreté qui nous est vraiment assuré dans
l'approvisionnement par le nucléaire
mais aussi et nous devons engager
fortement le développement des énergies
renouvelable c'est toute la question de
la rénovation énergétique c'est toute la
question de la biodiversité là aussi
avec les parcs naturels régionaux les
régions s'engagent fortement nous devons
être dans des copes régionales nous
voulons les mettre en œuvre et nous
commençons à apprendre selon les les
territoires qu'il pourrait y avoir des
copes
départemental et je le dis très
clairement je suis et régionaliste et
départementaliste je ne participe pas à
cette volonté de supprimer les
départements mais sur la question de
énergie sur la question de l'écologie
soyons sérieux sur la question des
énergies renouvelables nous avons besoin
de territoires larges de territoires
larges pour pouvoir
développer la question de
l'hydroélectricité la question de
l'éolien flottant ne peut pas se traiter
à l'échelle d'un département ou même en
dessous quand on veut développer la
question de la méthanisation nous avons
besoin de souffle nous avons besoin
d'une
mutualisation et ça c'est indispensable
parce qu'à travers la question de la
méthanisation c'est bien entendu la
question des énergies renouvelables mais
aussi c'est un revenu pour nos
agriculteurs et cela il ne faut pas
l'oublier parce que c'est cela la
nécessité de l'action publique de savoir
concilier de savoir conjuguer et de ne
pas stigmatiser de ne pas exclure ou de
ne pas juger alors nous devons continuer
à travailler alors madame la Première
ministre ce que nous souhaitons en effet
c'est pouvoir exercer des missions
ensemble qui répondent aux objectifs
gouvernementaux et pour le bonheur des
Français tout simplement ce que nous
voulons vous dire c'est que nous vous
tendons la main bien entendu
saisissez-la
aujourd'hui la France
elle est menacée dans ses fondements
républicains alors il ne faut pas se
tromper d'adversaire il ne faut pas se
tromper d'adversaire et l'énergie elle
doit être là pour consolider la
République et lutter contre les
extrémismes et contre les populismes
parce que nous devons faire réussir la
France parce que si ce sentiment de
désespoir se propage s'amplifie à ce
moment-là c'est l'extrême droite qui
gagnera et cela républicain que nous
sommes nous ne l'accepterons
jamais
et nous présidentes et président de
région de France nous sommes nous sommes
attachés à cette France à cette France
qui est généreuse à sa devise
républicaine liberté égalité fraternité
bien entendu laïcité et face à ces
ennemis de la République nous nous
basseront pas les yeux ni la conviction
ni la force de combat parce que c'est
nous qui
gagnerons notre main tendue c'est une
main bienveillante parce que la main
républicaine
elle construit elle caresse la main
républicaine elle ne menace pas comme
l'extrême droite alors c'est une main
tendue c'est un appel un souffle de
Saint Malot cela fait suite à celui de
Marseille en 2018 pour plus de
décentralisation cela fait suite à celui
de Fort de- France qui a été porté par
l'ensemble des territoires d'outrem
c'est bien sûr l'appel qui émane de la
collectivité territoriale de Corse et
bien sûr j'excuse Gilles Siméoni et
Nanette monpertui puisque et c'est
logique accompagnant monsieur le
Président de la République cet appel
fait suite aussi aux propositions émise
par la Région Île-de-France et comme
vient de le faire l chengérard par la
Région Bretagne pour plus d'autonomie
des régions pour agir à vos côtés et
puis le Sénat nous livrait récemment un
important travail de réflexion sur la
poursuite de la décentralisation dans le
cadre d'un groupe de réflexion présidé
par Gérard
Larcher
infatigable défenseur de la
décentralisation et que je remercie
également sincèrement pour sa présence
fidèle ce matin mais pour son appui à
mes côtés continuellement pour la
République bien entendu pour faire en
sorte que tous les Français soient
considérés des territoires ruraux comme
des territoires urbains alors nos
propositions parce que nous tendons la
main mais nous faisons des
propositions on ne va pas rester sur des
verbes on passe à l'action alors quatre
ordres et la Pyrénéenne que je suis va
devenir presque matelot alors le vent
dominant en Bretagne c'est le vent de
surrois ce sera donc celui d'une plus
grande autonomie
d'action plus que de moyens nouveaux ou
de compétences nouvelles nous demandons
de pouvoir pleinement exercer nos
compétences pour agir avec davantage
d'efficacité c'est ce que nous appelons
l'autonomie d'action lutter contre les
en vêrement de compéten supprimer les
redondances le livre blanc des régions
que nous avons élaboré en 2022 est un
document que nous avons concerté tous
ensemble travailler et sur laquel sur
lequel nous devons nous reposer
l'autonomie d'action en matière de
compéten éducativ l'éducation le bien le
plus précieux de notre République cela
veut dire renforcer l'autonomie
pédagogique des établissements et
conférer aux régions une plus large
autonomie
de gestion l'éducation et les lycées
sont le creusé de la promesse
républicaine et les enseignants ont une
tâche immense à accomplir nous devons
avoir une pleine autorité l'autonomie
d'action en matière des politiques
d'orientation cela veut dire conférer
aux régions une pleine légitimité une
pleine réalité pour agir dès le collège
puis au lycée et dans l'enseignement
supérieur pour
démocratiser la réalité de de la
connaissance des métiers mais également
la réalité des parcours de formation
pour lutter contre le déterminisme
social c'est ce que nous devons faire au
moment de l'orientation nous devons
renforcer l'égalité des chances de
chaque alève pour que chacun puisse
choisir son destin puisse être maître de
son destin l'autonomie en matière de
politique de l'emploi cela veut dire
donner aux régions une compétence
globale nous avons changer chère
ellisabeth sur le projet de loi qui est
sorti du Sénat sur France travail nous
avons quand même des amélioration à
amener parce que nous voulons avoir un
système qui est simplifié qui permet
aussi de s'adapter aux réalités
économiques aux réalités d'emploi des
bassins de vie il n'est pas question
d'avoir une politique nationale ou des
politiques régionales ce que nous nous
demandons les présidentes et les
présidentes de région c'est qu'au niveau
de chaque région nous puissions avec le
préfet de région avoir des déclinaisons
par bassin d'emploi par bassin de vie
parce que la réalité de vie elle est
forte différente et la la réalité
d'emploi selon qu'on soit sur le bassin
d'emploi sur le sud de l'Ardèche autour
de Colmar ou autour de saintmalot c'est
ce que nous devons faire pour ramener
les public les plus éloignés de l'emploi
vers le travail et puis bien sûr
l'autonomie en matière de politique de
mobilité alors hier nous avons eu une
réunion de travail très fructueuse où
nous avons mis les mains dans le camboui
avec le ministre des Transports et donc
madame la Première ministre je vous fais
une proposition mettons en œuvre des
Assises de la mobilité ferroviaire et de
l'intermobalité et sur le financement
des infrastructures et sur la question
de la
tarification parce que je ne rendrai pas
sur les conditions
d'annance pour le moins impréparé sur la
question du Pass si nous partageons
l'absolue nécessité d'avoir des tarifs
attractifs des traines pas chers il est
absolument nécessaire que les trains
soient à l'heure et sur la question des
retards je peux être très rude dans les
négociations SNCF mais sur la question
des retards là aussi il faut parler de
la réalité pourquoi il y a des trains en
retard en France parce que c'est le
système ferroviaire le plus vieux
d'Europe c'est celui où il a été le
moins investi depuis des dizaines
d'années nous avons cette réalité et
nous devons prendre à bras le corps
cette vraie problématique l'Allemagne
investit trois fois plus dans son réseau
ferré que la France l'Italie investit
deux fois plus et donc nous devons avoir
un choc un investissement fort de la
part de la France et nous soutenons
aussi les présidents de région nous
avions fait une tribune il y a de ça un
an qui est une mobilisation des crédits
européens sur ces sujets nous savons que
le rail c'est le mode de transport le
plus écologique mais nous devons
investir massivement pour avoir des
trains à l'heure et pour avoir aussi des
conditions tarifèire attractive parce
que si nous voulons un vrai report modal
c'est cela la transition écologique
qui est absolument au cœur des
politiques menées par le ministre Béchu
et bien si nous voulons avoir un vrai
report modal il faut avoir une confiance
dans le rail et la confiance c'est par
la ponctualité et c'est par
l'attractivité des tarifs et c'est
pourquoi ces assises de la mobilité
ferroviaire et de l'intermodalité parce
qu'il faut arriver jusqu'à la gare et
bien on doit prendre à bras le corps la
question des fameux 100 milliards que
nous avions demandé il y a de ça 1 an et
nous avions cette ce chiffre n'avait pas
été donné juste dans un esprit
communiquant parce que nous y avions
travaillé c'est le besoin sur les 10
prochaines années et pour les
infrastructures et pour les ERTMS la
spécialiste des transports que vous êtes
comprenez parfaitement mon mon jargon
c'est la signalisation pour celles et
ceux qui sont pas donc trop ferru sur
ces sujets mais également le matériel
roulant et le matériel roulant aussi il
doit être dans la transition écologique
et énergétique le train à hydrogène va
circ
dans un an sur la ligne montrégeot
Luchon qui m cher mon territoire natal
parce qu'à côté des usines Alstom ce
train à hydrogène il est financé au 2
tiers par les régions un/ers par l'État
en Allemagne la proportion est inversé
nous devons développer les trains à
batterie nous devons développer les
trains hybrides tout cela je vous le
cite pour vous démontrer que
l'innovation dans ce pays elle existe
elle existe et nous avons une industrie
des transports qui est majeure et
derrière à travers cet investissement
c'est bien sûr bon pour la planète mais
c'est bon pour la souveraineté
industrielle et c'est pourquoi nous
défendons qu'il ait un Airbus
ferroviaire au niveau européen nous
avons connu les préventions il y a de ça
quelques années de la Commission
européenne par rapport à des conditions
de respect de la mise en concurrence la
concurrence mais sur le ferroviaire sur
les transports mais elle est
internationale et depuis maintenant 5
ans la Chine a bâti un grand groupe
industriel s'appelle CRC et crrc est en
train d'avoir les marchés sur le
continent américain et sur le continent
africain cette avance technologique que
nous avons en France que nous avons en
Europe il est absolument nécessaire de
la préserver et de la développer c'est
ainsi que nous aurons aussi la fierté
d'avoir une reconnaissance à
l'international pour relier les gens la
patrie des Droits de l'Homme et bien
elle doit aussi continuer à à relier les
populations alors l'autonomie
l'autonomie dans la République c'est
bien sûr aussi pour les régions
d'outremer pour les collectivité
territoriale d'outrem pour la Corse
c'est à la fois la reconnaissance
d'histoire et de culture spécifique qui
enrichissent notre patrimoine commun et
le renforcement d'une capacité à
apporter dans la proximité des réponsse
très différentes de Cell qui ont
habituellement en cours sur le
territoire métropolitain cela vaut
d'abord en matière réglementaire car
l'adaptation des lois au contexte des
outresères et de l'accord c'est une
nécessité
d'action mais cela vaut aussi sur le
modèle de la Nouvelle-Calédonie en
matière d'exercice des compétences
lorsque la région ou la collectivité
territoriale s'estime en mesure de se
substituer à l'État dans une démarche de
subsidiarité reposant sur une confiance
réciproque confiance là aussi aussi
c'est essentiel en Corse à la Réunion en
Guyane en Martinique en Guadeloupe à
Mayotte mais aussi à Saint-Pierre et
Miquelon à Saint-Martin l'attachement
aux couleurs du drapeau français est
fort et j'ai pu le constater ces derniè
mois en étant à la Réunion oui
l'attachement aux couleurs du drapeau
français est fort et cela n'allève rien
à la volonté légitime d'une plus grande
autonomie d'action par rapport à un
cadre rigide venu de la métropole car au
fond c'est d'une autonomie à la carte
nous en avons la maturité politique pour
renforcer la capacité à agir dans la
proximité et en fonction de l'analyse
partagée de la situation entre l'État et
les régions et cette autonomie d'action
elle n'est possible qu'à trois
conditions ce sont les ventses de nos
rois davantage d'autonomie fiscale bien
entend entendu nous demandons
d'avoir une fiscalité plus forte que ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui je tiens à le
rappeler quand parfois j'entends
certains représentants de l'exécutif
s'agacer quand les collectivités locales
que soit communal départemental régional
ont un problème elles appellent l'état
oui mais par force on est mis dans une
situation de dépendance on est
complètement lié aux dotations le budget
des régions c'est 95 % des dotations
quand vous avez que % de marge de
manœuvre quand il y a un gros problème
bien entendu que nous faisons appel à
l'état parce que l'État l'a voulu depuis
des
années l'affaiblissement de l'autonomie
fiscale des régions
remonte à la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle c'était il y a de ça 13
ans et donc nous devons avoir plus
d'autonomie fiscale et surtout avoir une
fiscalité en lien avec les missions
parce que nous investissons fortement
dans dans l'économie nous investissons
fortement dans le commerce l'artisanat
l'industrie nous investissons fortement
dans les start-ups dans la question
aussi de nouvelles technologies qui sont
liées au métiers vert qui sont lié aussi
la
nécessaire capacité à avoir des métiers
du fer des métiers de l'industrie mais
le bénéfice c'est plutôt sur le bloc
local ou intercommunal et c'est pourquoi
nous demandons d'avoir la substitution
des impôts 10 voitures façon communément
à une fiscalité qui est liée à l'action
économique et par exemple l'impôt sur
les
sociétés
fiscalité je tiens bien sûr à vous en
parler ici en Bretagne méditerranéenne
que je suis aussi ayez une attention
particulière madame la Première ministre
pour la question du changement de
fiscalité sur le carburant pour nos
pêcheurs parce que cela va avoir un
impact très complexe sur la viabilité de
nos métiers liés à la pêche et nous
devons être dans une prise en compte de
cette filière qui est au combien
essentielle mais qui est au combien
fragilisé depuis des années et puis
autonomie fiscale et puis autonomie bien
sûr de de gestion et c'est une
composante indissociable de la libre
administration alors pas de contrat de
chaor ou pas de contrat de chaor
maquillé nous savons quand même détecter
cela de l'OIN et puis davantage
d'autonomie réglementaire l'autonomie
réglementaire c'est l'inverse de
l'inflation normative qui paralyse
l'action des collectivités leur coûte
plus cher chaque année Françoise Gatel
sénatrice d' Villen et donc la
délégation au collectivité territoriale
à la décentralisation au
Sénat conduit un un travail important
sur l'impact des normes nouvelles pour
les collectivités ce rapport il donne le
le
tourni presque le mistral qui nous
bouscule cher Renault c'est donc un
stock de 400000 normes la dgfl estime à
2 milliards d'euros le coût des normes
nouvelles pour les collectivités entre
2017 et 2021 4 ans 2 milliards d'euros
alors nous demandons une autonomie
réglementaire des régions qui soi
reconnu et renforcé
madame la Première ministre chère
Élisabeth le nouveau souffle de C Malot
c'est un appel à accroître ensemble
notre efficacité collective par la
confiance la confiance c'est le vent de
nordé qui accompagne les journées
chaudes et ensoleillées de l'été en
Bretagne j'évoqué devant vous voici un
an la confiance comme un pilier
fondamental pour pouvoir rebâtir notre
République à laquelle nous sommes
passionnément attachés confiance pour
nos concitoyens confiance utile pour
être dans l'action dans le Progrès
partagé et au service de la population
la confiance à laquelle nous aspirons
elle requier désormais que nous
dispusions de l'autonomie que nous
permettra de rendre enfin toute notre
part dans nos objectifs partagés nos
objectifs réussis c'est cela que je
tiens à rappeler vos succès sont nos
succès nos succès sont vos succès parce
que c'est le succès de la France
alors le poète René charard que
j'affectionne
particulièrement a écrit une belle
expression c'est que l'esprit du château
fort c'est le pont Levie alors devant la
citadelle de Saint Malot en fait le pont
Levie madame la Première ministre c'est
la main tendue et c'est la confiance
entre les régions et l'État je vous
remercie et voilà pour le discours de
Carole Delga la présidente de région de
France en direct de saint-malot Carole
Delga qui a lancé l'appel de Saint-Malo
pour un nouveau souffle Gérard Larcher
va prendre la parole dans quelques
secondes et on attend Élisabeth borne
qui va s'exprimer pendant ce temps on va
regarder ce qui se passe du côté
d'ajaaco à l'Assemblée de Corse où
Emmanuel Macron a pris la parole pour
s'exprimer devant les élus de Lille on
parlera de son discours un petit peu
plus tard on va retourner du côté de
Saint-Malo gér l'archer va prendre la
parole le Président du Sénat on l'écoute
Monsieur le Maire de saintbalot en sa
commune cher Gill Lurton madame la
présidente de région de France
présidente de la région Occitanie cher
Carole delgard monsieur le Président
délégué président de la région sud cher
Renaud Muselier monsieur le Président de
la Région Bretagne cher loï chîn Girard
monsieur le V président délégué des
départements de France cher Jean-Léon
duup
pont monsieur le premier vice-président
délégué de l'Association des maires de
France et président d'intercommunalité
cher André liel Mesdames et Messieurs
les
présidents de région et collectivités de
métropole et d'autres m mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
parlementaires chers collègues
conseillers régionaux monsieur le
Président des césaires de France cher
Dominique vienne nous nous rencontrerons
cet après-midi monsieur président du
céser de Bretagne Mesdames et Messieurs
les élus Mesdames et Messieurs les
agents des collectivités territoriales
permettez-moi de vous dire d'abord
combien je suis heureux de me retrouver
parmi vous aujourd'hui dans cette cité
de saint-ballot par vant de survoir dont
l'histoire les personnages illustres ont
fait voyager nombre d'entre
nous qui ne s'est jamais rêvé le sabre
au cler en corser comme surcouff ou en
écrivain comme château brillant je vous
avoue que je me suis bien gardé la
semaine dernière lors de l'accueil du
roi Charles II au Sénat de citer
Surcouf mais méditer ces paroles de
Surcouf lors de la prise du Kent alors
que l'officier anglais
l'apostrophé en lui disant nous anglais
nous nous battons pour l'honneur et vous
français vous vous battez pour l'argent
Surcouf répondit chacun se bat pour ce
qui lui manque ça me semble extrêmement
clair
oui monsieur le Maire de saint-malot je
vous ai très attaché à cette histoire
malouine comme le monte la restauration
initiée du château de la brillanté dont
vous avez obtenu le classement
votre votre projet de musée
maritime mais aussi une politique
volontariste je pense notamment à cette
question que je retrouve partout dans
toutes les assemblées départementales
auprès des élus qui est celle de la
désertification médicale et je pense à
votre combat en faveur du futur hôpital
territorial mais aussi et le président
de la régionbretagne l'a évoqué vos
actions pour permettre au malouin de
rester habités dans leur cité en
limitant les possibilités de location
saisonnière par quartier ou en
développant les projets faisant appel au
bail réel et solidairire asite une
question importante dans les cités et
régions touristiques que le logement des
locaux des jeunes et des salariés qui
travaillent dans ces entreprises j'en
profite pour vous alerter de nouveau
madame la Première ministre sur la grave
crise du logement que nous nous allons
vivre si nous n'agissons pas de nombreux
français risquent de se retrouver sans
logement comme les étudiants en
septembre rapport sénatorial poait déjà
en 2021 un manque de
250000 logements étudiants en septembre
l'Union étudiante estimait un chiffre
encore supérieur sans parler d'ailleurs
des conséquences pour les entreprises du
secteur du BTP VI monsieur le Président
vous saluez loï chîn Girard président de
région Bretagne c'est vrai que c'est une
région dans une des îles du Ponant a une
place particulière dans mon cœur oui une
région attractive fière de son identité
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure
grande région agricole industrielle et
maritime tourner vers l'innovation et
notamment les biotechnologies qui sait
fédérer les énergies de ces territoires
une région investie pour l'avenir je
pense puisque c'est notre thème
aujourd'hui à la transition écologique
vous avez créé une assemblée bretonne de
l'eau monsieur le Président regroupant
tous les acteurs mais aussi le
développement de la production d'énergie
locale en particulier le photovoltaïque
déployé sur les lycées de la région oui
vous l'avez dit seul le collectif peut
permettre peut permettre de réussir et
je le dis sincèrement je le dis devant
les membres du gouvernement madame la
Première ministre le collectif c'est
aussi et essentiellement avec les
territoires que nous devons le
réaliser voudrais saluer vous l'avez
fait madame la Présidente Carole delgard
Françoise Gattel présidente de la
délégation au collectivités territorial
sénatrice de ce beau département que
vous connaissez tous qui œuvre depuis
des années et va continuer à le faire
pour défendre les collectivités
elle préside notre délégation objectif
redonner de la liberté d'action en
luttant constamment
contre l'inflation normative qui nous
assomme j'y reviendrai je pourrais
saluer nos autres collègues du
département Sylvie Robert
vice-présidente de la Commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication je vous renvoie un
excellent rapport de
2021 sur les bibliothèques dont elle
rappelle à la fois le rôle culturel mais
aussi le rôle civique j'excuse Dominique
de Lège et je salue Daniel salmon membre
de la commission des affaires
économiques est ici présent j'ai évoqué
les engagements de la région Bretagne
pour préserver sa ressource en eau
j'aurais pu avvoquer à ce propos le
travail fait par Saint Malo notamment
j'ai regardé ça de près Monsieur le
Maire je dis toujours les gens le
travail que vous fait actuellement sur
vos canalisations pour diminuer les
fites la préservation des ressources
naturel doit être au cœur de nos
réflexions afin de préserver notre
planète et l'avenir des générations
futures sans attendre cette échéance
loitaine nous voyons déjà Mayotte les
soucis que provoque le manque d'eau j'ai
reçu l'ensemble des maires de Mayotte il
y a quelques mois et je dois dire que
cette préoccupation est là très
importante je salue donc votre souhait
cher Carole delg que je remercie moi
aussi pour la qualité de nos relations
d'en faire l'un des thèmes de votre
congrès au fond vous nous posez une
question
importante comment concilier C
avec le développement des territoires
dans ce domaine les régions ont un rôle
primordial à jouer en lien avec les
autres collectivités cher Andr Lel et
Cher jeanlon duupont
l'essentiel de la transition
environnementale se fera sur et par les
territoires
oui je le dis le rôle des régions
essentiel c'est un rôle au cœur des
solution par les politiques publiques
qu'ell mettent en place bien sûr en
matière de biodiversité de transition
énergétique de mobilité pour citer
quelques exemples mais aussi au travers
le rôle de catalyseur du dialogue
territorial sur les sujets
environnementaux je pense notamment
dernier exemple en date aux futures
conférences régional monsieur le
ministre Béchu du zan que nous avons
voté avec l'Assemblée nationale en
juillet dernier mais je pourrais aussi
citer les comités régionaux de l'énergie
dont le rôle sera me semble-t-il crucial
dans le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables sur ces sujets comme celui
de la planification écologique et de sa
traduction dans divers documents
stratégiques dans les mois qui viennent
je suis convaincu que l'impulsion peut
et doit venir des territoires dans une
logique ascendante plutôt que dans une
verticalité descendante
ce qui n'exclut pas madame la Première
ministre le nécessaire dialogue entre
l'État et les collectivités oui oui
chers collègues chers amis l'écologie
passe d'abord par les territoires par le
concret par le projet nos territoires
sont les premiers acteurs et faiseurs du
développement durable et de la
transition écologique la solution
viendra dans ce domaine comme bien
d'autes du dynamisme des territoires de
cette proximité avec nos concitoyens que
vous avez les uns et les autres
chevillés au corps et au cœur cette
nécessité de changer le fonctionnement
actuel des institutions d'en finir avec
cette gouvernance trop verticale que
vous évoquez madame la Présidente tous
les élus locaux la récl je peux vous le
dire après des mois et vous savez
pourquoi passer encore plus sur le
terrain dans plus de 25 départ
au contact des élus locaux oui oui les
élus locaux le réclament
elle est la seule à même de répondre à
la crise démocratique que nous
traversons car comme Carole derga je
suis inquiet de cette crise démocratique
qui traverse notre pays il est urgent
madame la Première ministre de repenser
les relations entre l'État et les
collectivités c'était déjà le sens de
l'appel de Marseille monsieur
en 2018 où les trois principales
associations d'élus avaient décidé de
constituer territoires unis pour
demander moins de verticalité tout
simplement plus de liberté
locale j'entends qu'il est désormais
depuis ce matin l'appel de saintallo
madame la
Présidente pour cela il est nécessaire
de rétablir la confiance oui c'est un
mot important entre l'État et les
collectivités cela signifie travailler
avec elle en mon des prise de décisions
il n'est plus possible que ces dernières
découvre à travers des vidéos sur
Internet ou des interviews sur Youtube
des annonces qui vont impacter leur mode
de fonctionnement voir leurs finances
sans contact préalable on ne peut pas
continuer à travailler
ainsi la gestion des
mobilités développement du train sont
des sujets très importants à la fois
pour nos concitoyens pour l'aménagement
de notre territoire mais aussi pour cet
objectif de transition écologique cela
nécessite un travail approfondi
collectif monsieur le Président de la
Région Bretagne et non des décisions
unilatérales je sais qu'un comité état
région a eu lieu hier vous l'avez évoqué
madame la Présidente avec le ministre
délégué au transport j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il y a avait encore quelques
aiguillages à passer pour les temps qui
viennent c'est naturel en matière
ferroviaire mais à un moment il faut
arriver vers l'objectif qu'on se donne
oui il est temps de replacer les élus
locaux au cœur des décisions de leur
faire confiance de libérer les énergies
locales un code général des
collectivités territoriales à méditer
quand même qui a triplé de volume en 20
ans un code de l'environnement multiplié
par 10 sur la même période ça n'est pas
tenable il faut pas s'étonner qu'autant
d'élus se désespèent surtout quand dans
le même temps on voit les violences
s'accroîre à leur rcontre ainsi que les
contentieux en tout
genre sur ces sujets le Sénat agit une
proposition de loi sur la sécurité des
élus locaux a été déposée le 26 mai le
26 mai dernier et il sera examiné très
prochainement dès la semaine du 9
octobre au Sénat nous avons adopté le 16
mars une charte de simplification
l'initiative de la délégation
collectivité territorial cher Françoise
Gatel signé par le gouvernement cher
Christophe Béchu maintenant passons de
l'intention à l'action pour reprendre
les propos même de Carole delg ce sera
me semble-t-il une des priorités ça
concerne pas simplement le gouvernement
ça concerne aussi les parlementaires
semble-t-il chacun nous sommes concernés
car nous sommes responsables de cet amas
normatif qui aujourd'hui nous paralyse
et nous enert alors oui il est plus que
nécessaire d'écrire cette grande loi de
décentralisation tant attendu et annoncé
à de multiples reprises par le Président
de la République notamment le 2
septembre 2022 en recevant le président
de l'Association des maires de France en
recevant le président des départements
de France et en vous recevant cher
Carole delgat après 8 mois de travail et
de nombreuses concertations notamment
avec vous les trois associations d'élus
territoriaux présents ce matin et je
voudlais vraiment vous en remercier nous
avons abouti au Sénat le 6 juillet
dernier grâce au travail de nos
rapporteurs François Noël buffet Mathieu
d'Arnaud et Françoise Gattel une fois
encore de plus cité à la publication de
15 propositions pour rendre aux élus
locaux leur pouvoir d'agir thème du
dernier congrès des Maes de France avec
une priorité donner tout son sens au
principe de libre administration des
collectivités avec un mot d'ordre la
simplification je vous ai adressé madame
la Première ministre dès le 7 juillet
dernier tout comme au président de la
République et je vous le dis nous les
traduirons en proposition de loi très
prochainement il s'agit pas de proposer
un Big Bang territorial auquel personne
ne tient mais de faire des propositions
très pragmatiques très concrètes il
s'agit de gérer en proximité ce qui peut
l'être de fameux principes de
subsidiarité cher à David lisenard à
Aristote à Thomas dquin et aussi not
demden chacun y aura ses référence mais
ça veut dire ce qu'on peut faire mieux
en proximité c'est mieux de le faire
ainsi plutôt que dans la verticalité
c'est très clair
alors nous proposons d'améliorer les
conditions d'exercice des élus pour
rendre madame la ministre le statut plus
attractif et plus protecteur un travail
a été engagé avec le Gouvernement en la
matière il est nécessaire d'aller au
bout de la réflexion en prenant en
compte l'ensemble des collectivités nous
y prendrons toute notre part nous
souhaitons aussi renforcer l'agilité
territoriale à la main des élus locaux
en facilitant les expérimentations
locale et la différenciation
territoriale nous sommes déjà
investi sur ce sujet au moment de la loi
3DS terre d'expérimentation en matière
institutionnelle en Bretagne ça n'a pas
commencé
hier vous avez fait le choix du
volontarisme et notamment avec la
rédaction d'un rapport rendu la semaine
dernière monsieur le Président réclamant
plus de liberté au gouvernement en
matière de mobilité et la création hier
du syndicat mixte associant l'ensemble
des acteurs concernés ou encore en
matière d'emploi et de formation tout
comme d'ailleurs la région Île-de-France
qui a délibéré la semaine dernière en
faisant 43 propositions pour un choc de
décentralisation en
Île-de-France vous avez vous-même madame
la Présidente énuméré les propositions
pour un souffle nouveau en matière
d'éducation d'orientation d'emploi de
mobilité des expérimentations d'ailleurs
qui peuvent s'appuyer sur la législation
actuelle cependant là aussi pour que ces
expérimentations fonctionnent il faut
faire confiance aux collectivités pour
ne pas revivre l'expérimentation
déésevante de la délégation de la
culture en Bretagne qui n'a pas pu
fonctionner car certaines institutions
et je vais les nommer la DRC par exemple
ont eu peur de disparaître à la faveur
de ces expérimentations
oui nos territoires ont des spécificités
c'est pour cela qu'il est important de
leur permettre de pouvoir exercer
certaines compétences de manière
différenciée sans pour autant toucher à
l'unité de la
République il en est ainsi de la Corse
bien sûr où se trouve actuellement le
président de la République je
rencontrerai pour ma part le président
du conseil exécutif de Corse très
prochainement de même pour les outres
mèes donc je salue ici les représentants
nombreux quelques visages que j'ai
partagé il y a pas si longtemps chez eux
il est important comme nous l'évoquons
dans nos 15 propositions de rénover le
cadre institutionnel qui leur est
applicable pour dépasser l'opposition
entre assimilation et spécialisation
législativ et adapter ainsi les facultés
de différenciation au besoins de chaque
territoire s'il le souhaite s'il le
souhaite je vous rappelle que le Sénat
sera toujours garant de l'unité de la
République pour que les choses soient
claires elles soient clairement dites et
que chacun le sache au-delà de ces
propositions en faveur de la
décentralisation nous voulons aussi un
état déconcentré madame la Première
ministre accompagnateur facilitateur qui
ne soit plus senseur et pour
cela il faut que les
préfets retrouvent pleine autorité sur
les services de l'État dans leur
département et leur région car à
décentral tion forte il faut un état
territorial fort c'est comme ça que je
vois l'avenir me semble-t-il pour
redresser notre
pays nous proposons aussi dans le
rapport d'instaurer une véritable
autonomie financière et fiscale des
collectivités avec un panier de recette
clair pour chacune d'entre elles
renvoyant complètement un système de
financement à bout de sououf refonde de
la DGF
des règles de
péréquation si le projet de loi de
finance 2024 que nous aurons examiné
prochainement prévoit un certain nombre
de mesures en direction des
collectivités notamment la prise en
compte des dépenses d'aménagement dans
le calcul la FCTVA nous continuons à
maintenir sous
perfusion un système à bout de souffle
comme l'écrit d'ailleurs la région
Bretagne dans son rapport il faut je le
redis revoir en profondeur le mode de de
financement des collectivités en leur
redonnant une part fiscale
significative comment imaginer que les
principal ressources fiscales des
régions qui représente à peine plus de 5
% de leurs ressources proviennent des
transports carbonés qui en vocation nous
le souhaitons tous à diminuer alors
qu'une de leur principales mission vise
justement à développer le
ferroviaire même si des évolutions SEM
se faire jour en la ti il y a encore
bien des débats je pense au versement
mobilité et à la baisse des péages sur
le ferroviaire notamment il est
important d'aller plus loin dans
l'autonomie fiscale tout comme pour les
départements qui font face à une
situation financière inquiétante avec la
chute brutale des droits de mutation à
titre onéreux alors que dans le même
temps les dépenses sociales augmentent
sans parler des communes qui sont en
première ligne qui ont perdu la plupart
de leurs recette directes espérons que
la nouvelle méthode prenée par le
ministre délégué au compte public qui
souhaite associer pleinement les
associations d'élus aux réflexions sur
le redressement des comptes publics
trouve sa concrétisation et en tous les
cas qui ne trouve pas sa concrétisation
à casor de sinistre
mémoire notre rapport rappelle aussi la
nécessité à laquelle vous êtes attaché
madame la Présidente de consacrer le
principe constitutionnel de réexamen
régulier du droit à compensation
financière
des collectivités territoriales au titre
des compétences transférées il s'agit
vous le voyez de mesures concrètes
fondées sur la liberté et la proximité
seul gage d'efficacité de l'action
publique je l'ai dit au président de la
République lors de la rencontre de Saint
nique comme vous le savez madame la
Première ministre nous étions ensemble
une rencontre qui doit impérativement
aboutir sur des actions concrètes
on peut plus décevoir une nouvelle fois
les Français les élus locaux il faut
agir et l'action passe par la proximité
la
décentralisation cette main tendue du
Sénat à SaintDenis j'espère que le
Président de la République et le
gouvernement seront la saisir le
président a évoqué dans son contte-rendu
de cette rencontre d'ailleurs le rapport
du Sénat je veux y voir un geste
encourageant et je viens de lui apporter
hier d'ailleurs ma nouvelle
contribution oui avec la main
républicaine tendue il ne faut pas
craindre la décentralisation madame la
Première ministre elle est une des
réponses au défi d'aujourd'hui alors un
grand auteur Monsieur le Maire enterré
sur la pointe du Grand Bé à saint-ballot
écrivait le péril s'évanouit quand on
ose le regarder c'était François René de
Châteaubriant alors je pense que que si
nous voulons voir les périls s'évanouir
il faut oser les regarder en face les
traitter je pense que c'est ça le cœur
des solutions et vis-à-vis des
territoires je veux simplement reprendre
ce qui est la devise de saintmot
Saint-Père fidéliste je serai toujours
fidèle comme président du Sénat au
territoire vive la république et vive la
France
merci monsieur le Président du Sénat
Gérard Larcher le président du Sénat qui
demande au gouvernement de replacer les
élus locaux au cœur des décisions et de
leur faire confiance et maintenant
ellisabeth borne la première ministre
qui va prendre la parole ici à
saint-malot en direct du Congrès des
régions de France alors que Emmanuel
Macron vient lui d'achever son discours
à Jaco devant les élus de l'Assemblée de
Corse Emmanuel Macron qui s'est dit prêt
à l'entrée de la Corse dans la
Constitution une autonomie il a prononcé
le mot d'autonomie ayant l'audace
d'établir une autonomie à la Corse dans
la République une autonomie ni contre
l'État ni sans l'État c'est ce qu'a dit
le chef de l'État on va y revenir juste
après discourséabeth B cher Gérard
Larcher mesdames et messieurs les
ministres Monsieur le Préfet madame la
Présidente chère Carole Delga Mesdames
et Messieurs les présidents de région de
métropole et des
outremes Monsieur le Maire mesdame et
Messieurs les élus mesdames et
messieurs il y a un an devant vous je
prenais un
engagement toujours dialoguer toujours
construire des solutions
communes cette conviction de
l'efficacité du dialogue je l'ai forgé
tout au long de mon parcours comme
préfet de région comme chef d'entreprise
comme ministre et premierre
ministre plus que jamais c'est ensemble
état et
collectivité que nous pourrons atteindre
le plein emploi réussir la transition
écologique améliorer nos services
publics c'est ensemble en confiance
chère Carole que nous répondrons aux
attentes de nos
concitoyens mesdames et messieurs depuis
l'année dernière ce dialogue cette
volonté de construire ensemble sont le
fil rouge de notre action commune
je ne viens pas faire de grandes
annonces ou vous expliquer comment gérer
vos politiques publiques je viens
réaffirmer cet engagement pris l'an
dernier pour avancer pour être dans
l'action cet engagement s'incarne dans
une méthode de travail autour de trois
principes le premier c'est la
concertation nous échangeons beaucoup
chè Carole et avec chacune et chacun de
vous Mesdames et Messieurs les
présidents de région
ce dialogue danse et continue donne des
résultats je pense par exemple à
l'adaptation du Zéro artificialisation
nette que nous n'aurions pas pu réussir
sans les concertations menées par le
ministre Christophe
Béchu ce collectif des régions de France
est central il est un des piliers de
l'action
publque je souhaite que ces échanges se
poursuivent et je continuerai avec é à
la bonne association des régions et plus
largement des autres collectivités
territoriales grâce à nos concertations
nous avons désormais un véritable
programme de travail partagé c'était un
engagement du gouvernement et avec la
ministre Dominique fort nous l'avons
tenu l'ambition de l'agenda territorial
c'est justement de donner des
perspectives pour coconstruire nos
politiques publiques
les sujets sont nombreux transition
écologique mobilité attractivité pleine
emploi égalité des chances face à ces
enjeux nous devons tous avancer dans le
même sens avec optimisme mais aussi avec
lucidité je sais les questions
d'organisation de périmètrre et de
compéten entraînent des des
interrogations nous souhaitons tous des
responsabilités plus claire une action
publique plus efficace et c'est aussi le
sens du rapport du Sénat monsieur le
Président et je sais que vous partagez
cette ambition je sais que vous ne
souhaitez pas de bouleversement pas
bouleverser des périmètres
institutionnels ni créer de nouvelles
divisions alors je veux le dire
clairement toute évolution se fera avec
vous mon deuxième principe c'est la
confiance qui passe par le respect des
engagements
réciproque cher Carole Delga je vous
remercie pour la qualité de nos échanges
tout au long de l'année et pour la
relation de confiance que nous avons
construite j'entends vos attentes
s'agissant des perspectives financières
des région nous devons vous donner de la
visibilité nous devons soutenir
davantage l'investissement local et les
projets des élus et c'est ce que nous
faisons dès 2024 avec le FC TVA élargi
aux dépenses relatives aux aménagements
de terrain avec le fond vert pérennisé
et doté de moyens
supplémentaires pour autant nous devons
réfléchir à certains sujets je pense
notamment à la question du financement
des transports que vous souhaitez
renforcer mais aussi aux enjeux
d'intermodalité que vous avez évoqué des
travaux ont déjà commencé pour
déterminer les évolutions à mettre en
œuvre je souhaite qu'il se poursuivent
et qu'il s'accélère dans l'année qui
vient en mobilisant l'ensemble des
ministres
concernés enfin grâce à l'Union
européenne nous disposons de fonds pour
les collectivités en particulier pour
les régions l'accord de partenariat avec
la Commission européenne dote la France
de plus de 18 milliards d'euros sur la
période
2021-2027 la mobilisation de ces fonds
est cruciale pour financer les
infrastructures et les projet de vos
territoires ces principes sont
nécessairement généraux car ils
s'appliquent à tous les
territoires mais je veux vous dire que
j'ai pleinement conscience et c'est le
troisième principe de l'action de mon
gouvernement que nous devons tenir
compte des spécificités de chaque région
notre volonté est simple elle procède du
bon sens des réponses différentes à des
situations
différentes Bretagne par exemple cher
leï chegirard je sais les tensions
spécifiques sur le logement mais je
connais aussi la capacité des élus
bretons à travailler ensemble pour
répondre de manière cohérente aux enjeux
de votre territoire et je suis
consciente monsieur le Président du
Sénat que la situation appelle aussi des
réponses nationales nous y travaillons
cet après-midi même avec les ministres
concernés pour proposer au plus vite aux
différents acteurs et au Parlement des
réponses à la hauteur de la situation
mais sujet par sujet nous devons vous
donner des marges de manœuvre vous
permettre
d'innover dans ce cadre plusieurs
expérimentations ont déjà été lancées je
pense notamment à notre engagement en
matière de transition écologique dans
votre région Provence Alpe Côte d'Azur
cher Renault et je précise que c'est la
demande que j'ai faite au préfet en
cette rentrée après échange avec avec
les élus locaux me faire remonter les
attentes en matière d'expérimentation de
déconcentration de différenciation de
dérogation alors n'hésitez pas à
interpeller vos préfets sur vos
propositions cette différenciation
s'applique naturellement au territoire
ultramarin j'ai présidé cet été un
comité interministériel des outremè le
premier depuis 4 ans il a permis de
prendre des ement fort notamment contre
la vie chère ou pour la jeunesse
ultramarine l'application de chacune de
nos mesures fera l'objet d'un dialogue
étroit avec les collectivités je pense
en particulier à l'évolution de l'octroi
de mer mesdames et
messieurs
concertation confiance
différenciation c'est sur ces principes
que je souhaite continuer à bâtir notre
relation pour que nous constr
emble des solutions pour notre
pays pour ces prochains mois l'une des
priorités de mon gouvernement c'est le
plein emploi nous y parviendrons
ensemble en réussissant la réforme de
France
travail aujourd'hui malgré un
environnement difficile la France
obtient de bons résultats économiques
meilleurs que ceux de nos voisins
européens et vous l'avez dit ch Carole
la croissance tient notre activité ne se
dément pas notre économie a créé 2
millions d'emplois en 6 ans et le
chômage est au plus bas depuis 40 ans
les réformes structurelles que nous
avons mené notamment la réforme de
l'assurance chômage et celle des
retraites permettent de dégager des
dizaines de milliards d'euros
d'économie à présent grâce à ces avancé
au talent de nos entrepreneurs et de nos
salariés notre horizon c'est le plein
emploi cet objectif j'y tiens
particulièrement parce que c'est grâce
au travail que chacun peut choisir sa
vie et sortir des destins tracés par son
talent et ses
efforts j'ajoute que le plein emploi qui
doit aller de paire avec le bon emploi
et c'est le sens de la conférence
sociale que je lancerai le 16 octobre
c'est la garantie d'un pouvoir d'achat
durable et pour atteindre le plein
emploi nous voulons continuer à
renforcer le lien entre la formation et
l'emploi c'est ce que nous avons fait
sur l'apprentissage et aujourd'hui notre
pays compte près de 900000 apprentis
trois fois plus qu'il y a 5 ans nous
reprenons cette logique avec la réforme
du lycée professionnel et bien sûr nous
aurons besoin des régions sur l'enjeu
crucial qui est
l'orientation nous voulons aussi un
accompagnement renforcé pour celles et
ceux qui sont les plus éloignés de
l'emploi comme nous l'avons fait avec le
contrat d'engagement jeune c'est tout le
sens de la réforme de France travail
France travail c'est la volonté de mieux
coordonner nos actions en préservant le
rôle essentiel des régions et je salue
en ce sens les partenariats noués depuis
le début des
expérimentations avec déjà six régions
qui s'y sont engagées et je n'ai pas de
doute que territoire par territoire quo
nous trouverons les bonnes
organisations enfin je voudrais évoquer
le sujet de la formation
professionnelle indispensable pour que
les publics éloignés de l'emploi
puissent sortir de la précarité et
retrouver durablement un emploi de
qualité avec vous nous prolongerons les
pactes régionaux d'investissement dans
les
compétences comme je le disais la règle
c'est la visibilité financière au
travers de ces pactes nous nous
engageons sur les qu prochaines années
au total nous nous investirons 3,9
milliards d'euros d'ici
2027 dans une période de baisse du
chômage c'est un engagement considérable
que nous allons désormais décliner
région par
région mesdames et messieurs cet
objectif de plein emploi nous ne
pourrons l'atteindre sans le retour
d'une industrie forte dans notre
pays jeis que cet objectif est largement
partagé par les régions de France je
compte sur votre engagement
ensemble nous avons inversé la tendance
et l'emploi industriel revient depuis
2017 nous avons enregistré 300 créations
netes d'usine 100000 emplois industriels
supplémentaires et nous continuons à
attirer les
investisseurs les emplois industriels ce
sont souvent des emplois mieux rémunérés
que dans d'autres re secteur c'est cette
industrie que nous voulons dans tous nos
territoires mesdames et messieurs
l'industrie n'est pas revenue en France
par hasard c'est le résultat des
réformes structurelles qui ont
transformé notre économie et amélioré
notre
compétitivité aujourd'hui les
territoires français possèdent chacun
des atouts spécifiques je pense par
exemple à la métallurgie en Bourgogne
franchectée cher MARG marégit au creusau
à la filière hydrogène en Occitanie cher
Caro ou en Pays de Loire cher
Christel encore cette année pour la 4e
fois nous sommes le premier pays
d'accueil des investissements étrangers
nous devons ensemble pours poursuivre
cette politique
d'attractivité trouver du foncier
disponible et adapté à
l'industrie garantir l'accès à une
énergie propre à un prix compétitif
décarboner
l'industrie ensemble nous portons le
projet de loi industrie verte ensemble
nous déployons le plan France 2030 pour
accélérer la transformation des secteurs
clés de notre économie par
l'innovation en moins de 2 ans ce sont
plus de 20 milliards d'euros engagés au
profit de tous les territoires urbains
et ruraux métropolitains et
ultramarins la méthode est la même
construire des réponses
différenciées et je veux saluer
l'engagement des régions sur le volet
territorialisé de ce plan 12 régions
métropolitaines et tr territoires
ultramarins ont d'ors et déjà
contractualisé avec
l'État je le disais la
réindustrialisation doit nous permettre
d'accélérer sur la transition
écologique c'est un levier important
mais notre planification écologique va
plus loin c'est un plan global pour
tenir nos objectifs de réduction des
émissions restaurer la
biodiversité adapter notre pays au
changement climatique et protéger la
santé de nos
concitoyens après une première année
d'élaboration du plan à l'échelle
nationale nous démarrons une seconde
phase la mise en œuvre et le déploiement
concret de nos mesures avec la
territorialisation de la planification
écologique que porte le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires Christophe
Béchu et je tiens à ce que cette
planification soit le fruit d'un travail
partagé entre l'État et les territoires
les actions venues d'en haut imposé
depuis Paris nous savons que cela ne
marche pas pour être efficace nous
devons faire converger travaux nationaux
et remonter des
territoires dans cette perspective et
parce que les régions sont les chefs de
fil de l'aménagement du territoire
l'échelon pour la réflexion stratégique
et la
planification je lance aujourd'hui les
cops territoriales elles seront
coanimées par les présidents de région
et les préfets de région et j'entends
vos interrogations mais nous serons
forcément d'accord chère Carole car
c'est ensemble état et région que nous
déciderons de la forme des séquence de
la méthode et des modalités de travail
dans le respect de la cohérence
régionale et des compétences de chaque
collectivité ces cops doivent permettre
une prise de conscience collective de la
marche à Franch à franchir pour réussir
la transition écologique à tous les
échelons bien sûr nous ne partons pas de
zéro de nombreuses instances et projets
existent déjà mais justement la démarche
s'appuie sur l'existant et ne duplique
ni les structures ni les
initiatives notre objectif est d'aboutir
à un plan un plan d'action partagé avec
tous d'ici l'été prochain autour d'une
ambition
incontournable atteindre nos objectifs
de baisse des émissions de déploiement
des énergies renouvelables ou encore de
restauration de la
biodiversité je sais pouvoir compter sur
vous en particulier dans le domaine si
crucial des
mobilités un sujet que vous connaissez
bien cher Fran
vous avez un rôle central à jouer en
tant qu'autorité organisatrice des
mobilités et vous connaissez mon
attachement personnel à ce rôle qui a
été consacré par la loi d'orientation
des mobilités que j'ai
porté l'an dernier nous lancionss
ensemble les travaux de révision des
volets mobilités des contrats de plan
État-région les mandats de négociation
ont été adressés en juin dernier sur la
base du rapport du Conseil d'orientation
des
infrastructures ces mandats traduisent
notre ambition préparer notre pays à
l'enjeu majeur de la décarbonation des
transports au total ce sont 8,6
milliards d'euros qui ont été mis sur la
table par l'État avec un effort sans
précédent pour les mobilités décarbonées
notamment les infrastructures
ferroviaires le développement des
services express
métropolitains des transports collectifs
et le vélo
je sais que les négociations sont en
cours et que vous échangez régulièrement
avec vos préfets de région ainsi qu'avec
le ministre Christophe Béchu et le
ministre délégué Clément bunne je
souhaite que la majorité des
négociations puisse être conclue d'ici
la fin de l'année ce sera un jalon
déterminant de la mise en œuvre de la
nouvelle donne ferroviaire que vous
appeliez de vos vœux et que j'ai annoncé
en début
d'année vous le voyez les défis sont
nombreux et pour constater nos réussites
collectives pour identifier les freins à
lever les simplification à apporter je
souhaite que nous fassions un point
d'étape dans 3 mois avec l'ensemble des
présidentes et présidents de
région mesdames et messieurs j'ai tracé
les grandes lignes de notre action
commune au service de nos
compatriotes sur le plein emploi la
réindustrialisation
ou sur la transition écologique nous
savons nous parler travailler ensemble
et mener à bien des projets
importants par-delà nos étiquettes
politiques et les désaccords partisans
nous agissons au service de l'intérêt
général Mesdames et Messieurs les
présidents de région nous sommes engagés
différemment chacun dans ses
responsabilité mais nous sommes toutes
et tous au service des Français et je
sais que nous voulons agir pour offrir
des solutions à nos
concitoyens voilà ce qui nous rassemble
voilà ce qui doit nous pousser à
construire et avancer ensemble cette
année encore vive la République vive la
france merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre je vous propose de rester sur
scène si vous voulez bien c'est la fin
de ce congrès et la traditionnelle photo
qui accompagne chaque fin de congrès
j'invite tous les les élus les
présidents de région à monter sur scène
autour de la première ministre et les
ministres également qui sont présents
dans cette salle pour immortaliser ce
19e congrès des régions de France Merci
à
vous on va revenir en direct sur Public
Sénat voilà ellisabeth borne qui a donc
conclu ce 19e congrès des régions de
France et les présidents de région
présents qui vont donc monter sur scène
pour la rejoindre ellisabeth bande
Quentin euh qui a prononcé à de
nombreuses reprises le mot de dialogue
et le mot de confiance oui et le mot
ensemble aussi hein on voit que
effectivement il s'agit de montrer que
la méthode est différente que on se
parle alors ça a été évoqué dans les
discours il il y a bien eu des quakques
encore récemment notamment sur le le
Pass transport qui a été annoncé fa août
et par l'exécutif sans que les régions a
été mis dans la boucle mais malgré ces
petits quakqu récemment on voit que en
tout cas dans les mots il y a la volonté
d'apaiser cette relation entre
l'exécutif et et les collectivités
locales toujours dialoguer toujours
construire euh plusque jamais c'est
ensemble que nous allons faire a bien
dit la chef du gouvernement et elle a
même dit que ce dialogue depuis l'année
dernière c'était le fil rouge de la
relation avec l'État et les
collectivités donc elle elle insista
beaucoup sur ce dialogue après faudra
voir comment ça se passe dans les faits
dans la mise en œuvre de l'action de
l'État parce que on le disait il y a
encore quelques semaines et ben on a vu
des quques dans ce dialogue ouais on
voit cette photo de famille les
présidents de région réunis autour
d'Élisabeth borne avec des ministres
aussi on a vu Christophe minist de la
transition écologique la ministre des
collectivités également Dominique fort
qui est au côté d'Élisabeth borne
ellisabeth borne qui l'a dit d'entré
Stéphane elle vient pas faire d'annonce
mais elle vient elle vient retisser
finalement la relation avec les régions
oui ben cétait comme l'année dernière
c'est comme l'annéeavant en fait moi
j'ai l'impression que rien ne change
pour tout vous dire donc je retiens
trois choses il y a deux fois trois mots
qui reviennent qu'est-ce que dit
Elisabeth Bour concertation confiance
différenciation mais encore une fois
c'est c'est c'est c'est des mots et des
propos qu'on entend régulièrement et le
c'est le dialogue le fil rouge c'est
très bien mais c'est la relation elle
fait le yoyo sans arrêt depuis 7 ans
entre entre l'État et les collectivités
donc c'est un coup je te fais des
promesses ça va bien on discute et
cetera puis un incident hop on fait
marche arrière et on recommence donc je
je je encore une fois je trouve que
c'est très bien c'est très bien mais ce
sont des mots et au-delà des mots il
faudrait que les choses se précisent et
après dans la deuxème partie par de son
discours elle utilise trois autres
termes et elle disent qu'elle attend des
régions a raison puisque en fait elle
elle elle pointe trois trois trois
secteurs dans lesquels les enjeux sont
énormes qui relèvent des compétences et
du savoir-faire direct des régions et si
l'État veut avancer sur ces trois dans
ces trois domaines il aura
nécessairement besoin de s'appuyer et de
travailler en relation directe avec les
régions c'est plein emploi
réindustrialisation et transition
écologique bah oui encore une fois c'est
c'est très bien dans les dans les esprit
dans le mais je reviens à ce que je
disais avant le la prise de parole euh
Elisabeth borne par exemple évoque le le
le le mandat pour les négociations dans
le cadre des contrats de plan Etat
Région sur le sur le sur le train c'est
super mais ce on les a attendu un an en
fait il y a un retard assez assez
considérable la planification écologique
c'est c'était une promesse de campagne
très forte en 2022 tout le monde
attendait ils ont mis 4 14 mois pour la
bâtir alors c'est bien mais qui prennent
le temps d'élaborer d'élaborer tout ces
tout tout tout tout ça mais pendant ce
temps là on a l'impression si vous
voulez qu'il y a des mots à un moment et
puis et puis dans la mise en œuvre et
ben ça patine on nous parle
d'accélération bah il est temps de s'y
mettre il y a deux autres sujets sur
lesquels on reste sur notre fin et on
les avait entendu être évoqués par les
précédents orateurs en l'occurrence
Carole Delga Gérard al chez Carole Delga
elle a demandé davantage d'autonomie
fiscale on le sait c'est le nerf de la
guerre he les budgets des collectivités
locales elle elle elle a mêmeexpliqué
que 95 % des dotations des régions sont
en fait directement des dotations venues
de l'État les marges de manœuvre des
régions sont plus que sur les 5 derniers
% de leur budget ce qui donc fait qu'ils
n'ont plus de leviers fiscaux pour les
collectivités locales et de son côté
Gérard archer lui il a appelé à relancer
la révision des des institution pour
donner plus de marge de manœuvre sur le
terrain aux collectivités locales et
notamment et bien sans faire de Big Bang
territorial permettre la différenciation
permettre des choses des
expérimentations dans les dans les
régions et ça effectivement on en parle
dans les congrès de de de ces
collectivités locales depuis des années
et on voit que ça n'avance pas j'ai même
retrouvé des citations d'Élisabeth borne
en octobre 2022 où elle donnait des des
des conditions à cette révision
constitutionnelle et et un changement de
modèle en parlant de transférer les
compétences en donnant des ressources
dynamiques et adaptées ou encore en
donnant une capacité de différenciation
et en donnant de nouvelles
responsabilité aux collectivités locales
ça c'était il y a un an on voit que
depuis un an ces dossiers-là n'ont pas
avancé et qu'il y a pas de nouvelles
annonce ni sur la fiscalité ni sur le le
statut dans la constitution des
collectivités locales ça c'est
particulièrement intéressant à un moment
dans son discours Carol Delga dit bah
oui en gros les régions aujourd'hui la
fiscalité qui va aux régions en dehors
des dotations et cetera c'est l'impôt
voiture principalement c'est-à-dire une
part de des parts de fiscalité qui sont
lié euh à à l'activité des des voitures
dans les régions les ces grises et
cetera c'est débile h c'est débile si
vous voulez faire la transition
écologique le principe c'est qu'il y a
moins de voiture en circulation donc
c'est-à-dire que en fait les les on va
demander aux régions de s'investir dans
une démarche qui consistera à les privé
d'une partie de leurs ressources donc
Carol Delga dit bah oui il faudrait que
qu'on qu'on qu'on touche une partie de
l'impôt sur les sociétés il y a une
autre piste par exemple
elle a complètement raison quand elle
dit que sur tout ce qui est éolien en
mer et cetera mais ou médanisation des
choses comme ça il y a il y a le le le
le bon échelon pour ces projets là c'est
l'échelon régional pour plein de raison
or aujourd'hui par exemple il existe un
impôt une taxe particulière qui
s'appelle diffire l'impôt sur le sur le
sur les le le comment l'impôt
forfaitaires sur les entreprises de
réseau pour qui touche les entreprises
de de réseau et notamment énergétique et
télécommunication et cetera le produit
de cet impôt va aux communes et au
département alors les communes elles
sont impliqué dans le développ
de l'éolien ou des des petites unités
dans la transition écologique à
l'échelle de leur territoire et pas les
département le bon échelon c'est la
région c'est stupide ça aussi c'est ça
fait partie des choses qui qu'on aurait
déjà dû régler depuis depuis depuis
longtemps il faut réorienter ce ce ce
genre de chose mais encore une fois ça
se dit depuis des années et ça ne se
fait toujours pas ou tout à fait on va
écouter Gérard Larcher parce que il a
pris la parole juste avant ellisabeth
borne et le président du Sénat on le
sait qui est un fervant défenseur des
collectivités et qui uvre pour ce
dialogue entre l'État et les
collectivités il a il a dit qu'il était
urgent de repenser les relations entre
les collectivités et l'État on
l'écoute il est urgent madame la
Première ministre de repenser les
relations entre l'État et les
collectivités pour cela il est
nécessaire de rétablir la confiance oui
c'est un mot important entre l'État et
les collectivité cela signifie
travailler avec elle en amont des prise
de décisions il n'est plus possible que
ces dernières découvre à travers des
vidéos sur Internet ou des interviews
sur Youtube des annonces qui vont
impacter leur mode de fonctionnement
voire leurs finances sans contact
préalable on ne peut pas continuer à
travailler
ainsi quel rôle il peut jouer Gérard
Larcher dans dans ce dialogue entre
l'État et les
collectivité bah aujourd'hui ah bah le
le rôle le premier rôle Gard Larché
c'est que en tant de en tant que
président du Sénat c'est c'est quand
même la chambre qui représente les
territoires et pour le coup il connaît
la France il connaît les élus il connait
les problématiques il le montre dans son
discours il a un certain nombre de de de
comment de de mentions spéciales pour et
pour le maire de saint-malot et pour le
président de la Région non mais enfin
voilà et c'est pas c'est un des élus
aujourd'hui c'est un des élus de la
République qui connaît le mieux la
France je suis désolé enfin on dira on
peut dire ce qu'on veut sur sur gché
mais il est tout le temps en déplacement
et cetera il il est au contact il fait
il est il est capable de de de créer ce
un lien que aujourd'hui l'État
manifestement est très en peine dans le
dans le dans dans le dans le dialogue
vous voyez bien que on parle de
confiance la confiance ça se décrète pas
ça se construit orors là pour le coup
euh euh encore une fois euh tous ces
tous ces tous ces discours tous ces mots
on les entend régulièrement mais il faut
il faut il faut que ce soit suivi suivi
dans les actes donc je pense que pour
répondre à votre question Oran je pense
que Gérard Larcher il est en capacité de
de faire le GO betwin j'aime pas le
terme mais le le le lien le lien entre
entre entre entre ces élus locaux qui
sont dans le doute qu' le sentiment de
pas être compris de pas de prêcher dans
le vide et un gouvernement qui dit qu'il
veut faire plein de choses mais qui
arrive qui a beaucoup de mal à à faire
la soudure et ben c'est le c'est le
c'est le bon c'est le bon ambass c'est
le bon ambassadeur et c'est le bon
interlocuteur pour pour faire ce lien et
Gérard March Quentin qui a qui a reparlé
de cet appel de Marseille he cétait en
2018 c'est là où s'est fondé
l'association Territoire uni dont vous
nous parliez tout à l'heure et et dont
Gérard Larché est un peu le le 4e
mousquetaire oui d'ailleurs ça c'était
beaucoup fait au Sénat les réunions de
de de territoires Unis lorsqu'ils
avaient des conférence de presse c'était
régulièrement dans des salles du Sénat
le Sénat qui se revendique la chambre
des territoires alors qu'il l'est
constitutionnellement parlant lorsqu'il
y a un projet de loi qui concerne
l'aménage du territoire oou les
collectivités locales il est toujours
examiné en premier au Sénat donc c'est
bien que ce rôle de relais des élus
locaux lui est reconnu dans la
Constitution d'ailleurs voilà on
ninvente pas le mode de scrutin d'un
sénateur ce sont les élus locaux qui
lisent les sénateurs à 95 % on l'a vu au
sénatorial dimanche dernier ce sont des
conseillers municipaux leurs
représentants qui élisent les sénateurs
donc bien sûr ils se font l'écho de de
ces élus locaux et de cette France voilà
qui est qui est dans la périphérique qui
est aussi comme comm cela moins moins
concentré qu'à Paris et c'est ce qu'il a
redit dans dans cette dans cette
allocution général arché il a dit il
s'agit de gérer en proximité ce qui peut
l'être et c'était aussi un message à
l'époque de Dominique buer qui était le
président de l'Assemblée des
départements de France il disait gardez
le régalien l'état garde le régalien le
gouvernement s'occupe des des fonctions
les plus
importantes et en l'occurrence
l'éducation la justice ou encore la
police mais laissz faire au plus près de
l'échelon local les compétences dans les
départements ou dans les régions ou dans
les communes lorsque ce sont les élus
locaux qui connaissent le mieux les
difficultés les problématique sur le
terrain donc là c'est exactement ce même
message qui est la continuité
effectivement depuis 2018 et territoire
uni c'est de demander cette élan de
déconcentration à nouveau parce que il y
a la vision recentralisatrice d'un
Emmanuel Macron qui voilà conscentre
beaucoup de pouvoir et qui a du mal à
laisser faire et qui a du mal à donner
des compétences aux échelons locaux et
et quand Gérard Larché part de cet appel
de Marseille on le rappelle en en 2018
il dit aujourd'hui il y a l'appel de
saint-malot c'est ce qu'a dit Carole
Delga ce matin l'appel de saint-malot
pour lancer un nouveau souffle est-ce
que ça rejoint un peu ce que vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure Stéphane
c'est-à-dire que 5 ans ont passé et on a
toujours au même point bah oui alors
avec peut-être des ajustements à la
marge mais enfin les demandes les
demandes les grandes demandes restent
les même là il y a eu beaucoup de
beaucoup d'expressions autour de et dans
le discours de de Gérard Larché dans ce
Carol Delga autour de la différenciation
du droit à l'expérimentation en gros
c'est laissez-nous faire laissez-nous
faire on connaît nos territoire on sait
quels sont nos besoins on a envie on
voit bien dans quel dans quel sens il
faut aller on veut bien le faire avec
vous mais laissez-nous faire donnez-nous
les moyens de faire des choses adaptées
et à nos besoins et à nos spécificités
locales et et on on voit
que on reste dans la théorie beaucoup
c'est-à-dire que on se dit plein de
choses mais mais mais c'est compliqué de
passer le cap et d'aller dans le dans la
réalisation dans la réalisation concrète
il y a eu un mot de de de de Caro Delga
sur le sur les pêcheurs je sais pas si
on peut en en dire un mot mais oui
mais comment il y a la fin des aides au
gasoil qui est programmé une compens une
compensation qui correspond pas à ce que
les à la hauteur de ce quiétait les les
aides et là il y a un gros conflit mais
en Bretagne l'enjeu est énorme il faut
quand même réaliser que 20% en fait en
France 80 % du poisson qu'on
mange 80 % du poisson qu'on mange est
importé les 20 % restants c'est le
produit de la pêche française locale et
la Bretagne pèse pour moitié de ces 20 %
de pêche donc en fait le la moitié du
poisson qui est pêché en France et par
des fr des pêcheurs français il vient de
il vient de Bretagne et c'est des
flottes de pêche qui sont pas du tout
des par rapport aux questions
environnementales ce sont pas des
flottes de de pêche industrielle c'est
pas des très gros bateaux c'est pas
voilà donc on est sur des sur des sur
des bateaux de 12 à 24 m c'est une pêche
très artisanale et et le problème c'est
que si le prix du gazoil est trop élevé
ces bateaux ne sortiront plus ils ne
pourront plus aller pêcher du tout et
donc vous voyez que par rapport au par
rapport aux préoccupations général
d'ensemble et cetera au discours là on a
en Bretagne sur ce secteur-là sur ce
sujet-là on a une situation locale
spécifique qui mérite peut-être une une
autre approche qu'une approche globale
et descendante et il y a plein d'autres
cas comme ça qui qui
qui Dominque bu j'ai j'ai retrouvé sa
cituation exacte en 2019 il disait dans
beaucoup de domaines l'État ne sert à
rien alors il avait un forme de Fran
parler à l'époque Dominique busr le
président de l'Assemblée des
Départements France il a toujours oui
ouii mais il il est plus oui c'est ça il
est plus président de de cette assemblée
mais voilà il disait qu' fallait que
l'État se concentre sur sur le régalien
on va vous l'avez beaucoup dit éisabeth
B qui appelé au dialogue à l'écoute on
va écouter un extrait du discours de la
première ministre sur la coconstruction
avec les
élus nous souhaitons tous des
responsabilité plus claire une action
publique plus efficace et c'est aussi le
sens du rapport du Sénat monsieur le
Président et je sais que vous partagez
cette ambition je sais que vous ne
souhaitez pas de bouleversement pas Bou
des périmètres institutionnels ni créer
de nouvelles divisions alors je veux le
dire clairement toute évolution se fera
avec vous mon deuxième principe c'est la
confiance qui passe par le respect des
engagements réciproques nous devons vous
donner de la visibilité nous devons
soutenir davantage l'investissement
local et les projets des élus et c'est
ce que nous faisons dès 2024 avec le
FCTVA élargi aux dépenses relatives aux
aménagements de terrain avec le fond
vert pérenisé et doté de moyens
supplémentaires mais je veux vous dire
que j'ai pleinement conscience et c'est
le troisième principe de l'action de mon
gouvernement que nous devons tenir
compte des spécificités de chaque région
notre volonté est simple elle procède du
bon sens des réponses différentes à des
situations différentes voilà Élisabeth
borne qui appelle à la coconstruction
mais en même temps on a envie de dire
Stéphane que pouvait-elle dire d'autre
ce matin mais elle a pas le choix enfin
moi je trouve ça c'est c'est c'est c'est
bon c'est c'est c'est drôle en fait
lisabeth bornne dit que tout ce qui
concernera
éventuellement l'évolution des
institutions des modifications des
règles ne pourra pas se faire sans vous
monsieur le Président du Sénat mais
évidemment qu'elle peut pas faire sans
lui parce que de toute façon le
gouvernement n' n'a plus la majorité
absolue à à l'Assemblée et le c'est ce
ce ce le pouvoir aujourd'hui dans une
situation où de toute façon il ne peut
pas légiférer sans l'appui du Sénat
Quentin évoquait tout à l'heure le fait
que traditionnellement les textes qui
passent en première lecture à
l'Assemblée au Sénat pardon sont tous
ceux qui concernent les territoires
l'aménagement du territoire les
collectivités les élus enfin locaux ok
mais je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
mais depuis le début de ce nouveau
quinquena il y a une flopppée de textes
majeurs qui ne s'inscrivent pas dans ce
champ qui devrait en toute logique
passer d'abord à l'assemblée qui sont
d'abord examiner en première lecture au
Sénat oui comme le plein emploi est déjà
été examiné par le Sénat et il va
arriver ensuite à l'Assemblée nationale
ou l'immigration ou l'immigration voilà
mais il y en a il y en a mais sans arrêt
pourquoi parce que en fait c'est c'est
c'est le seul moyen aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement dont dispose le
gouvernement pour arriver à faire une
pression positive et efficace sur sur
l'assemblée ensuite donc on construit
d'abord les textes au au au Sénat pour
espérer qu'ils seront adopté en en
seconde lecture ensuite à l'Assemblée et
et et le le Sénat est est est
incontournable on est dans une dans une
situation où aujourd'hui le Sénat est
incontournable donc évidemment qu'elle
doit faire tout avec avec avec Gérard
Larcher et le petit coup de gueule sur
le sur le sur les annonces faites sur
YouTube
était assez savoureux mais il a raison
il a raison et là là encore une fois il
y a un décalage entre le le discours la
réalité et puis ce qui se passe juste un
très très court mot mais pour dire
simplement qu'elle donne rendez-vous
dans 3 mois pour un point d'étape avec
les présidents de région donc voilà ça
ça renvoie à la fin de l'année 2023 pour
les avancés peut-être de nouvelles
annonces sur notamment le sujet
institutionnel et celui de la fiscalité
alors Gérard Larché et Carole Delga qui
dans leurs discours ont tous les deux
parlé de la Corse parce que au même
moment au moment où se tenait le
discours d'Élisabeth borne à Saint-Malo
et cette séance de clôture à saint-mallo
Emmanuel Macron lui était devant
l'Assemblée de Corse devant les élus
pour parler de l'avenir institutionnel
de Lille on va écouter le chef de l'État
dans quelques instants mais d'abord on
va écouter Gilles Siméon le président du
conseil exécutif de Corse qui s'est
exprimé juste avant le chef de l'État et
qui a lancé un appel à Emmanuel
Macron le moment est enfin venu d'ouvrir
le chemin de l'espoir de la paix
irréversiblement enraciné et du projet
partagé la grande démocratie que la
France ne peut pas ne pas entendre et
respecter ce que les Corses ont exprimé
à travers leur vote ne pas tenir compte
du suffrage universel serait prendre le
risque de disqualifier la démocratie nul
bien sûr ne peut l'envisager voilà cet
appel de Gilles Siméon parce que ce
matin c'était important c'est important
ce qui s'est joué ce matin à l'assemblée
de cor Stéphane Emmanuel Macron étaient
très attendu évidemment par les élus sur
l'avenir institutionnelle de Lille oui
et puis moi alors je enfin je peux pas
être mauvaise langue mais il me semble
qu'il s'est passé plus de choses en cor
que que qu'assint voilà c'est-à-dire
qu'on a une première ministre qui arrive
en disant de toute façon je peux pas
faire d'annonce par contre si j'ai bien
compris le président de la républque lui
il y en a fait encore des annonces et
les annonces qui me paraissent quand
même assez majeurs puisque euh donc on a
on avait on suivait en en parallèle mais
je crois que le Président de la
République bah oui a dit que qu'il était
question d'une autonomie ni contre
l'État ni ni sans l'État mais mais
n'empêche que il ferme pas la porte au
contraire et falloir va falloir qu'on
nous explique ce que ça ce que ça veut
dire et et il est prêt à faire entrer la
Corse dans la dans dans la Constitution
donc euh là c'est pareil c'est c'est
quand même c'est pareil hein ça ça ça
veut dire aussi que qu'il y aura une
modification si on y va si si on va au
bout du bout qui a qui a une
modification qui prévoit donc une
modification de la Constitution et
peut-être que dans dans le paquet il
pourra il pourra en profiter pour mettre
d'autres choses donc là il y a il y a
vous allz loin Stéphan on va
l'écoutermanuel Macron puisque
effectivement pendant que que ce congrès
se termin à saint-malot Emmanuel Macron
s'est donc exprimé à Jaco devant les
élus de l'Assemblée de Corse on va
écouter tout de suite le chef de l'État
qui effectivement a employé le mot
d'autonomie devant les élus de
onécoute il faut aller plus loin et je
suis favorable à ce que soit étudié la
possibilité pour la collectivité de
Corse de définir des normes sur des
matières ou des compétences
transférées cette capacité
normative devra évidemment s'exercer
sous le contrôle du Conseil d'État et du
Conseil
constitutionnel c'est un vrai pouvoir de
choix démocratique et une grande
confiance ici faite
il s'agit d'ouvrir la possibilité d'une
gouvernance responsable et libre d'un
territoire ce qui est non seulement
compatible avec le mot et l'esprit de la
Constitution mais qui rendra également
la République plus forte plus concrète
plus
efficace la progressivité et
l'évaluation régulière devront
accompagner ce nouveau
fonctionnement il nous faut en la
matière je le crois
profondément
sortir de l'importation de tel ou tel
référentiel en miroir d'autres îles et
régions de Méditerranée et
d'Europe pour bâtir un référentiel qui
soit pleinement
Corse celui de la Corse dans la
République pour répondre aux besoins de
reconnaissance éviter de nouvelles
confrontations allons au-delà des totems
pour les uns des tabous pour les autres
autres au fond ayons
l'audace de bâtir une autonomie à la
Corse dans la
République cette
autonomie doit être le
moyen pour construire ensemble l'avenir
sans désengagement de
l'État ce ne sera pas une autonomie
contre l'État ni une autonomie sans
l'État mais une autonomie pour la Corse
et dans la
République le moment exige des uns et
des autres un esprit de responsabilité
et de
dépassement c'est ainsi que notre
jeunesse de Corse continuera de croire
en la démocratie et de croire en la
République l'enjeu est bien
celui-là tracer un cap d'espoir et bâtir
un équilibre stable pour les prochaines
générations Emmanuel Macron qui a on
lâché le mot devant les élus de
l'Assemblée de Corse Quentin le mot
d'autonomie oui tout à fait alors faudra
voir exactement ce qu'il recouvre
ensuite parce que il a aussi dit qu'il
voulait reconnaître les spécificités je
cite d'une communauté insulaire
historique linguistique et culturelle il
a quand même parlé d'un moment
historique hein de ce qui se joue avec
ce discours donc il l'a reconnu lui-même
c'est bien un pas majeur qui est franchi
dans l'acceptation des revendications de
certains élus indépendantistes
nationalistes cors et donc faudra voir
exactement jusqu'où on va parce que
lorsqu'il il cite la spécificité
linguistique est-ce que ça signifie par
exemple que la langue corse est reconnue
comme telle dans la
Constitution faudra voir exactement la
précision de de l'annonce parce qu'on
sait que ça pourrait coincer avec
notamment la droite sénatoriale on l'a
vu dimanche la droite et le centre qui
sont majoritaires à la Chambre haute du
Parlement et Emmanuel Macron qui va
avoir besoin d'une majorité des 3/5è des
deux Chambres du Parlement et donc qui
va forcément falloir trouver un
compromis a aussi avec la droite les
républicain qui peut être beaucoup plus
hostile à à cette définition dans la
Constitution on a vu Bruno rotao encore
ce matin dire par exemple qu'il ne
voulait pas un titre à part pour la
Corse dans la Constitution qu'il fallait
que ce soit dans l'article 72 donc tout
ça ça va se jouer alors ça sert des des
débats ensuite juridiques et cetera mais
c'est dans ce genre de détail que ça que
que vont se cacher voilà les précision
de de l'annonce ouais parce
qu'effectivement il a lâché le mot
d'autonomie Stéphan et vous l'avez dit
he il le dit une autonomie
ni contre l'État ni sans l'état il parle
de la Corse he dans dans la République
évidemment mais euh Quentin le le le
disait est-ce que finalement au-delà du
des mots ça va être faisable parce que
derrière il faut que le Parlement suive
mais c'est toujours le même problème en
fait mais moi ce que ce que je trouve ce
que je trouve étonnant enfin ou
intéressant dans la séquence qu'on vient
de vivre c'est que à Saint-Malo vous
avez des élus qui disent on veut de la
différenciation et et à Jaco vous avez
un président de la la la la la
République qui dit bonco parce que c'est
de ça dont il parle en fait l'autonomie
c'est aussi quand il parle des
spécificités et cetera c'est c'est
adaptons notre cadre réglementaire et
notre droit pour vous donner la liberté
de faire des choses que vous ne pouvez
pas faire dans le cadre commun comment
général et euh
et et ça mais est-ce qu'il a aussi passé
un message au président de région en
allant en disant en tout cas qu'il était
prêt à accorder l'autonomie à la Corse
est-ce que c'est un message à l'ensemble
des présidents aussi qui demande plus de
décentralisation moi je crois que c'est
d'abord un message qui est passé au cors
un contexte particulier donc voilà après
après encore une fois ça fait partie ça
aussi ça fait partie des revendications
qui sont portées depuis des années par
les élus locaux ça fait des années qu'il
y a un dialogue et cetera mais que mais
entre entre l'État central et et les élu
mais ça fait aussi des années que tout
le monde tourne autour du pot et que je
pense que d'une manière générale l'idée
c'est c'est quand même de se dire ce
serait bien à un moment d'arrêter de se
payer de mots et de passer à quelque
chose de concret donc les les les la
prise de parole du président de la
République en Corse aujourd'hui elle
peut déclencher ça aussi c'estàdire que
quand même il est il est je le trouve
assez clair c'est un engagement qui
prend et c'est assez ferme ça va être
difficile après de laisser le truc en
suspend en disant bah on en reparlera
dans 10 ans bah non non va falloir que
ça avance si ça avance autour de la
Corse je pense que c'est aussi
l'occasion d'avancer sur un certain
nombre de de de de de ces revendications
qui sont portées depuis depuis depuis
longtemps et peut-être de les faire
aboutir assez rapidement Gard archer qui
a dit dans son discours à saint-malot
qu'il rencontrerait prochainement Gilles
Siméon le patron de l'exécutif Corse
donc on voit que effectivement ça va il
va falloir que ça avance sur les deux
tableaux le chef de l'État fait des
annonces mais c'est bien aussi au
Parlement que ça va se jouer et que une
négociation va s'ouvrir sur exactement
ce qui peut se passer comment est-ce
qu'on définit cette autonomie de la
Corse et assez vite hein parce que le
chef de l'État Emmanuel Macron a dit 6
mois 6 mois il donne 6 mois pour un
texte constitutionnel ouais c'est voilà
c'est très audacieuxin on sait que c'est
c'est les textes c'est c'est le projet
de loi constitutionnel la révision
constitutionnelle c'est le plus dur à
faire passer vous devez jouer sur les
équilibres politiques des deux chambres
en même temps c'est déjà difficile
parfois de faire voter un texte dans une
seule des deux chambres alors surtout en
ce moment pour la situation de
l'exécutif donc réussir à faire voter
une révision constitutionnelle avec les
deux chambes du Parlement dans le
contexte politique actuel en 6 mois ça s
ça semble très compliqué mais on verra
comment ça va se se jouer exactement
ouais je vous rappelle qu'on a affaire
un président qui essay qui avait essayé
de faire la même chose pendant son
premier quinena et que ça s'est pas bien
passé non plus donc ouais avec la
difficulté peut-être pour les sénateurs
d'être dans une forme de paradoxe parce
qu'ils prôent eux la différenciation la
défens des collectivités et là est-ce
qu'ils peuvent se retrouver dans le rôle
de bloqueur c'est c'est toute la
difficulté notamment de la droite
républicaine qui est d'accord avec cette
idée de différenciation mais jusqu'ù
hein et ben pas forcément jusqu'à ce que
tout ce que demande les lcorse
effectivement et on aura évidemment
l'occasion d'en parler merci beaucoup
Quentin merci Stéphane d'avoir été avec
nous pour suivre cette clôture du
Congrès des régions à Saint-Malo et pour
suivre aussi ce discours d'Emmanuel
Macron en Corse qui a donc prononcé le
mot d'autonomie devant les élus de lîle
on en reparle évidemment demain matin
dans notre matinale Quentin merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous Stéphane
on regarde votre livre déjeuner secret
dans les coulisses de la réforme des
retraite voilà pour tout savoir de ce
qui s'est joué pendant ce moment-là
merci Stéphane merci à tous de nous
avoir suivi très bonne journée
[Musique]
je veux pas qu'on m'explique aujourd'hui
que si j'enlevais mon foulard je serais
plus libre ou je serais plus plus
française voyez ces résumés là on peut
pas aujourd'hui les accepter comme tel
20 ans avant le débat de cette rentrée
sur labaya la France débattait déjà du
voile à l'école
fin 2003 le président de la République
Jacques Chirac convoque une commission
de 20 sages composé d'intellectuels de
renom pendant 3 mois la Commission
stasie va effectuer près de 150
auditions avant de remettre un rapport
qui sert encore aujourd'hui de base à
l'interdiction de la BAA dans les écoles
françaises pourquoi une fillette doit
cacher sa chevelure son corps pour
quelle
raison derrière le voile dans les
coulisses de la commission stasie un
documentaire exclusif samedi à 21h sur
Public Sénat et aussi sur
[Musique]
publicsenat.fr pas simple de se faire
une place entre un père biologique
Francis de Courrière élu européen et
patron du club de foot du coin et un
père spirituel Jean-Louis borlot député
du Nord est maire de
Valencienne c'est pourtant ici que
Valérie lard a bâti toute sa carrière
[Applaudissements]
politique du collège al j'ai vécu en
fait le Valenciennois au moment où ce
territoire a connu une énorme fracture
en 10 ans sur les années
80 tout s'est écroulé fermeture d'Usinor
et fermeture progressive des mines et de
tout tout ce qui va avec c'est tout un
pon de territoire et une culture et un
lien au travail qui a disparu et qui
s'est transformé et qu'il a fallu et
bien prendre en compte absorber et
essayer de surmonter parce qu'il a fallu
réinventer un nouvel avenir à ce
territoire c'est en 1995 que Jean-Louis
borlot alors maire de la ville repère
cette jeune assistante social il lui
propose un poste d'adjointe le coup de
foudre est immédiat j'ai rencontré
Jean-Lou borlau par parce que
figurez-vous qu'à cette époque là il
recrutait et il cherchait à à construire
une nouvelle équipe pour la politique de
la
ville comment ça pass j'ai déposé ma
candidature j'ai été recruté après avoir
donc effectué des entretiens et en 91 je
me suis retrouvée directrice de la
politique de la ville à la mairie de
Valencienne et c'est là que j'ai
rencontré donc et bien Jean-Louis borlot
maire de Valencienne le terrain le
contact avec la
c'est son truc elle en fera d'ailleurs
un atout lors de sa conquête du Sénat
qu'elle rejoint en 2001 et du jour au
lendemain je me suis retrouvé dans les
hor de la République dans une assemblée
sénatoriale qui pour la première fois se
voyait appliquer la loi sur la parité et
dans les années 2000 quand on est une
jeune femme élue il faut sans cesse
faire ses preuves que j'ai la que j'ai
80s j dans une école j'intervenais il y
a les élèves qui ont dit mais on attend
le sénateur mais sénateur c'est moi mais
pas des jeunes sénateurs le premier
mandat que j'ai effectué je me suis fait
tout au long un point d'honneur à
travailler peut-être deux ou trois fois
plus les sujets et à faire en sorte je
me mettais comme beaucoup de femmes je
pense quand on est arrivé dans cette
première promotion entre guillemets a
montré qu'on était capable de faire au
moins aussi bien que nos collègues
hommes très vite elle adopte les codes
de la chambre haute la droite la gauche
peu importe qui est à l'origine des
textes du moment qu'ils vont dans la
bonne direction je suis centriste je
suis je suis effectivement issu de la
famille UDF simplement et je l'ai
toujours montré en région ça ne m'a
jamais posé problème de défendre un
certain nombre d'amendements quelquefois
de m'abstenir de faire passer un budget
qui n'était pas de ma sensibilité qui
était plutôt socialiste quand les sujets
et les projets qui étaient portés
allaient dans le sens de l'intérêt de ma
région partout où je suis passé je me
suis toujours intéressé j'ai toujours
été sensible au fait que sans économie
il y a pas de solidarité je me suis
toujours inquiétée de faire en sorte que
le les territoires et notre pays un
avenir économique et un rebond
économique mais ça a toujours été pour
moi pour embarquer le plus grand nombre
enfin voilà je suis libérale parce qu'on
est dans un monde libéral et on peut pas
le nier il faut agir dans cette
dimension là mais je suis aussi
profondément social parce que pour moi
sans solidarité on n'est pas un pays
moderne un pays moderne c'est un pays
qui n'a pas laissé de gens sur le bord
de la route et qui s'occupe des plus
fragiles pour moi la République s'occupe
d'abord des plus fragiles les hommes les
plus fragiles les femmes les plus
fragiles les territoires les plus
fragiles on doit avoir un cap une vision
un projet pour notre pays et notre
société et on doit embarquer tout le
monde sinon on fait pas société
travailleuse acharné Valérie lettard
s'impose en quelques années comme une
personnalité incontournable du Sénat où
elle contribue à faire avancer des
dossiers comme le revenu minimum
d'activité ou encore l'harmonisation des
prestations sociales Valérie lettard
rejoint aussi de nombreux clubs et
groupes d'amitié automobile chasse pêche
cheval bref la panoplie du sénateur
exemplaire c'est juste la la la
traduction de ce que je suis
l'utomobile je je suis valenciennoise
Alstom bombardier PSA Toyota Renault au
porte de chez moi on a réindustrié
réindustrialisé notre territoire autour
de l'automobile du ferroviaire et aussi
de tout ce qui touche à la logistique et
au numérique le cheval le cheval je suis
cavalière depuis toujours je suis d'une
famille où les chevaux ont toujours été
présentees la chasse la chasse j'ai un
mari lieutenant de
louveterie passionné de chasse et moi
j'avais de ans j'avais mon grand-père
agriculteur et mère de son village qui
m'emmenait à la chasse avec lui si je
viens d'un village rural où c'était bah
voilà la chasse ça faisait partie on
vivait à la campagne et c'était le
moment où on se retrouvait tous les
ouvriers du village avec le fermier avec
le maire et et voilà et c'est le fruit
de mon histoire et aussi de ma famille
la renommée nationale elle arrive en
2007 lorsqu'elle rejoint le gouvernement
de François Fillon c'est Nicolas Sarkozi
et et qui m'appelle directement
et j'étais dans valencienne je me
baladais et puis je décroche mon
téléphone il me dit bonjour Valérie je
t'appelle c'est Nicolas et je suis avec
François François Fillon voilà Valérie
je te propose si tu en es d'accord de
t'occuper des politiques de solidarité
au sein du gouverne voilà comment ça
c'est nommé jeune secrétaire d'État la
solidarité auprès de Xavier Bertrand
elle est notamment en charge des
personnes âgées et de la parité
hommefemme je pense qu'il cherchait
effectivement des élus qui a un profil
social et qui soi reconnu dans un large
spectre comme étant effectivement
crédible dans le paysage des politiques
sociales pour faire avancer une cause
qui lui tient à cœur Valérie lettard ne
se ménage pas quitte à monter sur scène
le temps d'une représentation d'une
pièce féministe jupe est un tourbillon
sauvage une bouffée d'air un pas de
tango la mini jupe est une initiation
une impression toutes les formes de
violence que ce soit en direction des
personnes âgées handicapées sont toutes
aussi lourdes à vivre mais aujourd'hui
on a encore une fois au travers de cet
acte la possibilité de mettre en lumière
ces sujets et de dire aux femmes allez-y
vous êtes librees parlez j'ai défendu
l'idée que il puisse y avoir une grande
cause
nationale de de de en fait mettant en
avant la lutte contre les violences
conjugales les violences faites aux
femmes et dans ce cadre là il y a eu
beaucoup d'événements qui ont été
construit pour essayer de mettre en
avant ces questions je me suis retrouvé
au milieu de femmes formidaes
sympathique que ça a été un moment
d'abord en même temps militant et bah
qui commençait déjà à mettre en avant
quelque chose et bien qui n'a eu de cess
que de revenir dans le paysage de notre
société puisque bah aujourd'hui on le
voit bien c'est même la grande cause du
quinena
après plus de 20 ans au Sénat Valérie
lettard a décidé de raccrocher sa
dernière intervention dans l'hémicycle
comme une évidence la politique de la
ville un dossier technique dans lequel
elle y met tout son cœur avec les
collectivités tous ensemble on réussira
ce Paris mes chers collègues je vous
souhaite plein de bonnes choses pour la
suite et voilà bon un petit passement au
cœur mais plein de bonnes choses c'était
mon dernier exercice parlementaire avec
des conséquences concrètes euh et et et
et et fait avec tous les gens avec qui
j'ai eu plaisir à
travailler cher Valérie lard il ne CIT
pas à la présidence de joindre de se
joindre aux applaudissements de
l'émicycle pour autant je je ressens la
même chose que ce que les collègues
viennent d'exprimer et je suis moi aussi
très ému de cette dernière
intervention
j'ai le sentiment de ne pas